hallo hallo funktioniert alles omega lull
max online what richtiges dance game
ich poste das glaube ich noch mal auf twitter ich war ewig noch mal an
ja wenn jetzt meine forts forscher noch richtig funktionieren würde hätte es
natürlich was sagt mir mal wie wie abmischung ist hintergrund sound um ein gelaber und so
also laut obs ist das ist das ganz ok
da ich poste das jetzt erst mal auf der da
perfekt so wunderbar also was wir heute machen übrigens ob ich den den chat unten eingeblendet
lasse müssen wir noch mal gucken klein also was wir heute machen ich meine prinzip steht
es ja schon im titel hast du schon die k95 ja habe ich das wollte ich euch gleich jetzt
mal ich wollte ich wollte euch eigentlich erst mal bevor wir anfangen was zu meiner
neuen tastatur erzählen aber jetzt muss meine vorschau erst mal richtig funktionieren die
backt übelst rum ich habe angeblich null zuschauer ich kann mein chat nicht richtig
lesen das liegt aber jetzt nicht an obs das liegt aber im zweiten rechner der komisch
rumspalten bestimmt das winners update das 100 pro das winners update weil ich habe
an dem rechner nichts gemacht der war jetzt einfach zwei monate war halt aus sein ich
nicht mehr gestreamt hab der zweite und jetzt aber vor irgendwie letzte wochen habe ich
irgendwie mal winners update gemacht und seitdem seit da spakt er jetzt rum habt ihr schon
das neue winners update gemacht das beste ist ja nildes ist ja das das das april update
was jetzt quasi im nicht nicht im april kam so also was wir heute machen ist wir müssen
noch was kleines programmieren morgen für die oder beziehungsweise für die e3 streams
die in nächsten tagen kommen weil ich werde das ganze auch wie gesagt es fängt morgen
an mit ea ich werde das ganze hier auch wieder streamen und wir können es ein bisschen lustig
machen über die ganzen scheiß da so gelabert wird zur tastatur sage ich gleich was wir
müssen nämlich noch was kleines programmieren aber erstmal was zu meiner neuen tastatur
das haben nämlich auch ein paar per twitter gefragt und zwar ich habe mir zwei neue tastatur
gekauft und zwar und zwar achtung einmal die hier von korsair korsair und dann noch einmal
eine ducky one two skyline das ist das eine ist so eine super übertrieben fancy rgb hast
du nicht gesehen tastatur das ist die die ich ja auch grad hab das erste was ich gemacht
habe ist da oben auf den knopf gedrückt auf den hier auf den knopf und hab auf den da
und hab erst mal rgb ausgeschaltet erst mal rgb ausgeschaltet die habe ich hier grad
am start und man hört sie auch schon das ist mechanische getippe und da habe ich mir
noch weil ich einfach mal vergleichen will habe ich mir noch die hier bestellt das ist
auch eine mechanische tastatur sind preislich gar nicht so unterschiedlich die korsair tastatur
kostet irgendwie 80 euro mehr was man muss muss man guckt leute ohne scheiß ne guckt
euch mal den preis von diesen dingen die sind noch nicht mal ganz dicht oder 190 euro für
eine tastatur sie vergoldet oder was ich werde für eine tastatur das ist schon ganz schön
geknackt oder ab 20 20 sekunden oder so ja also es ist total bescheuert aber ich hab
es jetzt so gemacht ich hab mir die hier jetzt also die im prinzip finde ich da finde ich
die hier vom layout und so ich finde die viel angenehmer das sieht halt aus wie so eine
0815 also optisch ist dieses ding sieht es aus wie so eine 0815 billig tastatur das ist
auch nicht so viel 80 euro billiger als die 60 euro billiger als die andere aber vom layout
her finde ich das viel angenehmer als das ding das problem ist nämlich so ein bisschen
hier sieht man es eigentlich ganz gut das ist halt das sieht man auch gut ja wir programmieren
gleich was dass man hier so was einpletten kann als overlay hoffentlich klappt das ich
bin ja nicht so der wpf hält so wenn man das mal so vergleicht das da zu dem da man
das ist natürlich viel abgespaceter hier das zeug von korsair aber ich komme mit dem layout
hier viel besser klar ist nicht ein bisschen laut jetzt das passt eigentlich so und ich
hab es jetzt so gemacht ich habe mir die auf die arbeit mitgenommen zum testen die habe
ich hier daheim ich habe das vor allem so gemacht weil sie hat halt makro tasten hier
neben dran wobei ich halt die software installiert habe aber da kommen wir gleich zu was ich
an der tastatur nicht gut finde was mir überhaupt nicht gefällt sind die kleinen windows tasten
natürlich will man sehr als gamer so wozu braucht man windows tasten ist overrated gebaited
activated outdated braucht man nicht aber ich brauche das weil ich verwende die windows
tasten zum desktop switchen also entweder entweder hier so windows desktop oder halt
auch auf wenn ich mal linux gestartet habe da verwende ich halt windows tasten und dann
zwei drei vier fünf für zum desktop durchschalten und wenn die windows so klein hier ist dann
treffe ich die manchmal nicht was auch doof ist dass die makro tasten hier sind ich war
in okay ich habe keine ahnung wo man die sonst hin machen sollte muss ich ehrlich sagen vielleicht
an die seite oder so das problem ist wenn man nicht hinguckt ja und wenn man nicht da der
krass trainierte zehnfinger blindschreiber ist der sich hier an diesen kleinen nippeln
auf den tasten orientiert dann hat man das problem dass man halt für instinktiv mit dem
kleinen finger den rand der tastatur sucht wenn man den control drücken will und ich
drücke so oft makro tasten 6 obwohl ich eigentlich control drücken will weil ich nachher ein
rand tastatur control so und das stimmt halt der restlichen dann ist dann a auf einmal
caps lock und das passt nicht das ist bei euch auch nee das hat aber gepisst mir gestern
nass geworden auf auf dem rückweg von der arbeit heute morgen nass geworden auf dem hinweg
von der arbeit auf dem rückweg heute glücklicherweise nicht so aber an sich ist diese tastatur wirklich
gut da kann man nichts zu sagen das ding ist natürlich komplett overpriced ja das ist viel
zu teuer viel zu viel viel zu teuer aber es ist gut ein vorteil hat das ding hier auch und ich
werde wahrscheinlich auch noch mal beide tastaturen vergleichen und am halben jahr erzählen in
irgendeinem video weil ich dazu denke ja pc lustig das habe ich mir auch überlegt ich mache
einfach control auf die makro taste das problem ist wenn ich wenn ich control auf die makro
taste mache meistens drückst du ja control zum ducken oder sowas und da drückst du control
und dann dann sucht instinktiv wer ist d und dann bist du dann anstatt auf wer ist d bist
da auf q caps lock d und a das das ergibt dann machst ja noch mehr kaputt wie die falsche
control taste drücken aber ich habe es natürlich schon da ist und was ich wirklich gut daran
finde ist dass die keine rahmen so richtig hat also ihr seht ja die tasten die stecken
quasi direkt auf dem metall untergrund drauf und das heißt selbst wenn man vom rechner
ist was ich mir jetzt schon die letzten jahre abgewöhnt habe und letzter zeit wieder angewöhnt
wenn man vom rechner was futtert oder es sei es auch nur was kleines oder irgendwas macht
oder es öfters sachen auspackt oder so sprich wo es krümel und fussel und sonst was gibt
dann fallen die hier nicht rein das hast du hier natürlich schon das hier ist eine ganz
klassische tastatur mit also vom vom gehäuse her da fallen halt die krümel rein wobei
es halt bei den switchen bei diesen bei diesen cherry wir müssen dann auch klein mal anfangen
zu programmieren sonst wird das ja nix bei diesen switchen da gibt es jetzt nicht so
viel wie bei einer bei einer rubberdome tastatur wo sich das irgendwie drunter klemmen kann
aber genug also ich gehe mal davon aus die tastatur wird schneller innen drin dreckig
wie die tastatur so war es jetzt so als vergleich also wie gesagt aktuell habe ich die man hört
sie auch am tippen glaube ich ein bisschen im hinterkonto mal kurz gucken wie der geht
eigentlich geht eigentlich ich meine ich haue jetzt auch ganz schön drauf so mal kurz gucken
also falls ich was überlege schreibt einfach noch mal schreibt entwupplose davor
little samsung schreibt schmutz sammelt sich einiges bei der razor dance game razor
die ergonomische tastatur komm ich damit klar übrigens weil mich die leute vorgefallen ich
zeige euch jetzt mal was ich für eine tastatur vorher hatte pass mal auf
und microsoft office übrigens ich ich gebe mir mittlerweile gar keine mühe mehr richtig zu
schreiben google auto corrected das je also ich habe ich hatte bisher immer eine microsoft
an microsoft office keyboard 1.0 a pass mal auf das ding ne das das da hatte ich bisher
immer so das ist der tastatur ich hab es jetzt hier nicht stehen sonst könnte ich mal drauf
gucken wie bauja oder so die liegt hier hinten auf dem sofa so und haben wir die vielleicht
immer ein bisschen größer genau das ding so und das geile ist ich meine die tastatur ist super ja
die war super das ist das ist zwar eine rubberdome tastatur aber die hatte schon zwar so eine der
ersten tastatur mit funktionstasten und so ein rad hier neben und so erst mal damals war das super
fancy und jetzt passt mal auf von wann das ding ist sieht man das hier also guck mal es endet
2005 schreibt hier irgendein typ im chip forum treiber gesucht das heißt ende 2005 hat er für
diese tastatur schon irgendwie nicht mehr offensichtlich sein zeug gefunden also ich
glaube die tastatur die ich hab die ist irgendwie von 2002 oder irgendwie sowas gewesen also sprich
die war ihr geld aber sowas von wert wenn man sich überlegt 15 jahre die gleiche tastatur und es
war ja an der bis jetzt nichts kaputt ich hab da zig mal was reingeschüttet oder sonst was und
das einzige was jetzt kaputt gegangen ist ist die ist die arrow down tast das ist alles mehr ist
mehr ist nicht kaputt gegangen in 17 jahren tastatur also das ist richtig pogas würde ich sagen
das ist massiver pogas ist das schon so und jetzt habe ich mir halt noch mal wieder was ich
meine wenn die auch nur annähernd so lange hält die korsal tastatur wenn die nur annähernd so lange
hält dann ist die ihre 180 euro oder sowas das scheiß kostet wert ich weil gehen wir mal gucken
was kostet was kosten auf amazon zur zeit amazon ja genau 195 glaube ich hab es ein ticken günstiger
was wo ich es bestellt habe aber die hier gefällt mir insgesamt vom layout her viel besser die
hat ein bisschen nervige makro programmier funktionen aber die hat auch hochwertigere
tasten die die die korsa hat so eine ganz normale ganz normale so plastik obendrauf
ist so glattes glattes plastik außer hier auf der lehrtaste und auf dem makro tast so
glattes plastik und die tastatur neigen ja dazu egal wie sehr man sich die finger war ein bisschen
fett hast du immer an den fingern ganz automatisch die werden die werden so so glänzend oben auf
den tasten und das hast du hier gar nicht die haben hier so eine die haben hier quasi noch
teurere tasten drin und es ist leider nix dabei hier mit mit hochgenauer auflösung dass man das
sieht weil wir größer als 20 megapixel gibt es echt okay jetzt gucken wir uns mal die
high res tastatur an vom bach von virus virus ist eingefangen hier oder auch nicht man sieht
was sind das für seiten hier wo man hier rauskommt man sieht man sieht es nicht richtig aber die hat
so eine beschichtung die ist ganz ganz leicht rau so aber jetzt müssen wir mal anfangen ich
werde euch mal kurz erklären was wir heute programmieren müssen weil morgen ist e3
stream morgen 20 uhr hier auf twitch die irgendwie ein hausten der dann wahrscheinlich random auf
einmal auf der auf der bühne erscheint und ich nicht weiß wer es ist so und wir gucken
uns hier wie gesagt nächsten paar tagen die streams an die zu normalen zeiten sind ich
glaube ich glaube ubi war drei uren nachts oder sony war irgend einer war drei uren nachts
das werde ich mir wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich nicht geben sebaro hat was tolles programmiert
hast du gemacht ja und man weiß man hat doch keine ahnung was bei ihr so dran kommt und
wir gucken uns das ganze zusammen an müssen natürlich auch ein bisschen ablästern über
das ganze weil wahrscheinlich wieder total viel bullshit dabei sein wird deswegen müssen
wir heute im stream wir müssen ein ea e3 2008 bullshit bingo sheet erstellen ganz wichtig
das brauchen wir da muss da müssen wir uns gleich mal ein bisschen überlegen was man
was man dafür nehmen könnte ja also eine sache die auf jeden fall morgen passieren
wird bei ea ist es wird wieder irgendein auto über die bühne fahren und es hat keine ahnung
warum das war nämlich die letzten e3 streams von ea auch immer so das einfach ist ein auto
über die bühne gefahren warum fährt das also jetzt da war was hat es damit zu tun und
dann kam dann noch irgendein typ der ausgestiegen ist von bmw oder so der erzählt wie geil
das auto ist irgendwann kam dann das neue also war total bescheuert und es kommt auch garantiert
für den random random youtube ist da auf die bühne wo ich mich dann wieder frage welches
das überhaupt ich kenne ja mittlerweile nicht mehr so und dafür brauchen wir um das ganze
ein bisschen aufzulockern eine möglichkeit sinnlose memes einzublenden auf knopfdruck
und wir können den ganzen stream heute abkürzen wenn ihr ein programm kennt mit dem ich auf
knopfdruck also quasi zum beispiel ich drücke steuerung l oder sowas und es zeigt mir quasi
einen png overlay über über allem an hat sich meine maus gerade irgendwie dpi runter
geht dpi fühlt sich irgendwie so an er ist auf achte achte passt eigentlich warum leuchten
meine maus denn ich habe das leuchten von meiner master ausgestellt logitech lull so
und das brauche ich also ein programm das auf knopfdruck bier transparente pngs auf
bildschirm anzeigt ich weiß dass ich das im obs machen kann aber in obs seh ichs ja nicht
da sehts ja nur ihr das ist die virenseite von vorhin
in dem bullshit bingo kann alles rein sowas von random youtuber erscheint auf der bühne
auto fährt über die bühne alles ja und irgendwie buzzwords oder irgendwie sowas da wusste wir
müssen es nicht so genau nehmen ja und full und full full screen brief hier auf dem 2 bildschirm
ist auch durf weil ich wills ja sehen hier direkt und ich habe auch kein bock über auf
dem 2 bildschirm zu gucken weil ich bin ich guck mir den stream an ich will dann quasi
einfach nur mal wenn irgendwas dummes passiert im stream will ich einfach mal eine taste
drücken und keine ahnung 5 mal hinter deiner lull einblenden oder so rip leute ich sag
ich war wirklich traurig an dem tag als als sie gepostet haben das total biscuit gestorben
ist das hat mich wirklich mitgekommen wusste der typ ist fast nicht auf den tag aber plus
minus ein paar monate ist er genauso alt gewesen wie ich das sieht mir sogar beziehungsweise
was heißt er sieht mir ich sehe ihm sogar ein bisschen ähnlich und es war wirklich
ich habe also das kann es nicht sein das hat mich wirklich mitgenommen gleich also es gab
im letzten jahren e internet hulk hat mich auch mitgegeben ich meine den leute ich kenne
sie nicht persönlich ja aber das waren alle leute die waren deutlich jünger oder gleich
alt wie ich internet hulk jetzt total biscuit es ist verrecken alle jungen leute ist doch
scheiße oder so und sowas will ich hier einfach mal in den streams dann einblenden können
per overlay und eins weiß ich jetzt schon windows forms kann es nicht katze was ist
mao mao meine katze guckt grad hinter mein rechner und ah ne es ist ok es werden kabel
eingefangen das ist in ordnung das können wir machen so und ich weiß jetzt schon mit
windows forms wird das ganze nix weil wenn aus forms hat es nicht so mit falls es jetzt
raschelt ist normal ich versuche gerade mein headset zu entwirren wenn aus forms hat es
nicht so mit transparenz deswegen müssen wir das wohl getrunken mit wpf machen und
ich habe von wpf eigentlich überhaupt keine ahnung aber das kriegen wir schon gebacken
mir war das mal neues projekt und das das wird was ganz kleines das wird vielleicht
100 150 zeilen oder so einfach nur hotkey da muss ich mir noch in hotkey library raussuchen
weil das machen wir nicht selbst weiß ich wie das geht unter windows das ist geil gewinn
weil das weil du pussycam geschrieben hast zeigt mir dass der twitch auto moderator jetzt
an ob ich das nicht löschen will so war es in der art warte mal ich guck mir das mal
an was er geschrieben hat was er gepostet hat ok wann kommt hier ja so ungefähr bloß
dass ich es halt auch selbst sehen will und auf knopfdruck einen ausblenden ja ja ungefähr
so was genau sowas so wpf projekt das nennen wir mal wie nennen wir das
an für das ding wie auch wenn wir nennen zwar ein bisschen sachlich das ganze ja mime
bort mime bort finde ich cool mime bort ist gutes gefällt katze was ist denn mau was
ist denn mau ja die geht voll ab neben mir gerade kann sich kann jetzt nicht ich gebe
dir gleich paar lecker ist aus der ruhe gebst ne herzlichen wau was ist das für eine schrift
hast du deine katzen kam noch im stream nicht ok ja mime bort finde ich mime bort finde
ich gut das machen wir so da ist das ding wpf zeug ist immer so übertrieben überladen
kautfenster kautfenster kautfenster ist quasi ein achtel vom bildschirm oder so wie wäre
es mit einer 27 grad drehung beim einfingen also ich habe von wpf schon nicht viel ahnung
wenn ich dann noch animation machen also wir machen eine animation wir machen drehen oder
sowas weil drehen ist gut habe ich mir überlegt wenn man sich hier wenn man beispielsweise
hier null wenn man hier lachen hat und da dreht sich nach links und ich kann es immer
wieder starten dann sieht es aus wie der lachen wisst ihr es dreht so dreht sich so nach links
so ihr seht es ja gleich ok also wie fangen wir denn jetzt am besten an kann man den scheiß
hier unten nicht mal zumachen halt nein weg brauche ich nicht wenn man braucht compiler
oder so komplett overrated so mein also habe ich gibt es ist zufällig irgendjemand da dass
ich mit wpf auskennt das könnte voll die business idee werden 0 3d kann wpf gifs kann
wpf gifs das müssen wir ausprobieren moment leute das müssen wir ausprobieren 0 3d gif
das muss ich jetzt mal testen ob das das kann save image wir machen uns auf dem desktop einen
ordner irgendwie folder 0 3d 0 3d hat er das jetzt ist es jetzt ein gif gif gucken ob wpf
das kann das wäre geil da könnte man sogar animiertes das probieren wir mal aus moment
image oh mein wpf zeug source so und jetzt müssen wir irgendwie diesen komisch warum
warum hat windows eigentlich so kackfade gucken ob mal gucken ob wpf gifs kann ich habe ja
so meine zweifel dass das geht ok anzeigen tut das schon mal aber er drehts nicht er
drehts nicht das wird mich aber echt mal interessieren wpf animatet ob das geht hat
max früher nicht immer chillstep gehaltet ich habe auch mal haftbefehl gehaltet zu
rechte sogar manchmal how do i how do i get animated gif work in wpf ok es gibt irgendeine
library view das ist gut das können wir nehmen aber erstmal erstmal machen wir was mit normalen
bilder danach können wir immer noch wir danach können wir immer noch animierte gifs einblenden
ok wir brauchen jetzt erstmal ein paar bilder zum testen also was lasst mal überlegen oder
was was braucht man was braucht man für quasi unverzichtbare memes für e3 live streams also
auf also ohne lull gehts schon mal geht schon mal nicht da sind wir uns einig oder und
ohne lull ist nicht möglich ich hätte ich hätte es gerne transparent ok also ohne lull
geht schon auf keinen fall was brauche man was brauche man sonst noch monka s brauche
auf jeden fall geht geht auch nicht ohne aber den hier auch irgendwo transparent weil transparent
brauche auf jeden fall im bild das können wir jetzt nicht alles selbst basteln ist er
transparent als save image monka s dance game high pass ne was brauche res oh resident sleeper
brauche man natürlich unbedingt gibt es jetzt irgendwie hoch aufgelöst annele ne annele brauche
man also erstmal erstmal brauchen wir hier haben wir resident sleeper mal irgendwie ein bisschen
höhere auflösung ist nix nix den brauche auf jeden fall ok wir nehmen zwar drei bilder
zum test ach ja wenn man wie wir auch brauchen wir unbedingt brauchen noch ist hier confused
ne der da wie heißt er denn genau confused den brauche ich auf jeden fall es geht sonst
nicht transparent gibt's den transparent irgendwo ok das ist bisschen klein das bild ok wir fangen
jetzt erstmal an ich war donation the fuck danke für die donation wenn ich jetzt noch
sehen sebar und 20 euro dankeschön ob das spend noch funktioniert klar funktioniert
das funktioniert funktioniert können vielleicht ich weiß bin mir nicht sicher ob es bei euch
funktioniert ich wollte ich wollte jetzt ich hätte jetzt normalerweise könnte ich ja mein
prime sub sellout machen aber ich habe ja keinen ich bin ja kein partnerausschnitt gibt's kein
prime sellout ok wie fangen wir jetzt am besten an ich muss mal ein bisschen ich habe viel zu
viel geschwätzt ich muss jetzt erst mal kurz in mich gehen so wir setzen jetzt erstmal das
ding auf irgendwie was ich weiß das funktioniert ok und jetzt müssen wir das fernster müssen
jetzt transparent machen weil sonst sieht es ja scheiße aus wir müssen das fernster
ausblenden und wir müssen das fernster transparent sein machen easy clap jetzt können wir alles
einbauen ist wir müssen jetzt ja erst mal das ding basteln mit dem was überhaupt anzeigen
können ok also ok jetzt kommen meine krassen wpf skills show taskbar oder sowas gibt's
falls wollen wir nicht wobei wir lassen wir noch mal drinne vielleicht müssen wir das
ding irgendwie beenden über die taskbar window mode gibt's glaube ich irgendwie window style
window window window style none wollen wir weil wir wollen ja kein gedürfnis drum herum
anzuhalten dann wollen wir irgendwas mit transparency allow transparency true so weil wir wollen
dass der hintergrund transparent ist von dem bild was eigentlich ist besagt wenn ich
das hier einblende ist ja total bescheuert das ist eine weiße box jetzt ist nur die frage
wie kriegt man jetzt das fernster transparent gibt es da sowas wie background das funktioniert
nice das ist doch schon mal gut das ist doch schon mal was jetzt können wir jetzt haben
wir hier unsere meme overlays schon mal wir können es zwar weder bewegen noch rotieren
noch sonst was aber wir können schon mal anzeigen so wir haben auch keine shortcuts
wo man das ganze ein ausblenden kann ja patrick ich krieg ich krieg mit bei xml krieg ich
auch immer anfällen ja poggers brauchen aber auch wirklich ja poggers transparent poggers
gibt es auch in groß vielleicht findet ihr einer von euch poggers in ordentlicher auflösung
können das ja mal im chat schreiben so jetzt müssen wir natürlich gucken dass wir das
die bilder noch irgendwie wechseln können das kann nicht allzu schwer sein ok also wir
haben als transparentes bild da war das mal so wir machen jetzt wir machen statische größe
scheiß drauf wir machen einfach das fernster ist 1000 mal 1000 groß und das bild ist keine
ahnung 900 mal 900 groß weil wenn wir das drehen dann brauchen wir noch ein bisschen
bisschen rand drum herum dass es nicht klippt
mal kann man was gucken leute ich das jetzt übersehen habe
ich bin mir ehrlich gesagt nicht so ganz sicher was ich davon halten soll weil ich mein microsoft
hat schon sau viel ihrer projekte auf github die sind mittlerweile sogar der größte glaube
ich zumindest größte open source hier kontributor das hätte man etwas mal einer zu bolmer zeiten
gesagt ja wolmer hat irgendwie die stühle nach den leuten geworfen damals laut berichten
microsoft macht in letzter zeit gar nicht so viel blödes sachen aber ich weiß keine
ahnung ich glaube das ist gar nicht so das problem github wird an sich weiter funktionieren
die frage ist was sie in zukunft damit machen ich hatte ja auch bisschen bedenken bei der
twitch übernahme von von amazon dass die ganz komische dinger machen sie machen ein paar
komische dinger aber alles in allem ist twitch die letzten wann haben sie übernommen eineinhalb
jahre oder so finde ich ist kontinuierlich immer besser geworden github ist übrigens
auf ruby und rails basis wenn es interessiert
wenn es wahnsinn das war so jetzt kann man den grämpel einblenden nu müssen wir mal
schauen ein bisschen vorwärts kommen ich habe immer absolut schneck schnecken tempo drauf
lässt man sich den code anzahlen ist ja schon schnecken tempo drauf wenn ich programmieren
im stream ja ganz wichtig wir müssen wir probieren jetzt wir müssen da noch noch rotation oder
so irgendwie rein basteln so also was brauchen wir denn da jetzt also wir müssen erst einmal
einstellen dass das fenster immer immer oben ist immer vor allen anderen fenstern weil
dann sieht man es ja nicht was was ich dafür ein tool programmieren dass das wird was kleines wo ich
irgendwelche mime bilder als overlay einblenden kann auf knopfdruck ich habe nichts gefunden ich
hätte mich auch gewundert dass es da nichts gibt aber irgendwie gibt es da nichts deswegen
müssen wir das selbst machen du hast ein poggers bild gefunden ne das ist kein poggers bild das
ist ein fields batman da muss man schon korrekt sein joshi ist finde ich nicht schlecht das finde
ich nicht schlecht dass das cover das bild das bild von joshi finde ich gut für awesome new
player fast experience so wir müssen jetzt aber erst mal das ding hier so weit basteln ok also
was ich machen will ist ich will verschieben können ich will auf jeden fall verschieben können weil
wobei will ich so will ich verschieben kann ja ich will es verschieben können ich will
verschieben kann aber vorher ich will es maximiert haben dass immer in der mitte ist oder will ich
verschieben kann ich ich will verschieben kann also das heißt wir müssen jetzt erst mal sagen
keine ahnung gibt es hier gibt es auch bestimmt auch so was wie mausklick maus daun ja maus daun right maus
left button daun das wollen wir haben und dann das habe ich vorher schon mal auch man kann einfach
sagen track das habe ich mir vorher auf deck overflow rausgesucht nicht dass ich das gewusst
hätte oder so und jetzt können wir nämlich das ding schon mal schieben schon mal ganz praktisch
diese geile windows shake funktion weiß jemand wie man die ausstellen kann ok jetzt können wir das
ganze ding schon mal moveen jetzt würde ich sagen machen wir dass das bild rotiert und zwar
rotation starten wir bei einem rechten button click und beenden sie bei einem rechten button
click hallo konsti 294 so wie macht man jetzt jetzt jetzt kommen halt dass ich eigentlich keine
ahnung von wpf hat also animation macht man irgendwie so das weiß ich kann das jetzt das
habe ich jetzt echt habe ich echt den virus hier jetzt wahrscheinlich hallo spack den kommer ok
also ne kratsch also man kann animation irgendwie story bock fack wie geht das wpf irgendwie mit
storyboard geht das animieren eine eigenschaft mit hilfe eines storyboards genauso was die
microsoft beispiele bist du immer erschlagen von ja so was hier will ich so was hier so was hier
so was hier will ich haben storyboard fehler ach so nie das muss in irgendein das muss in
irgendeinen resource block also ihr könnt mich zur wpf auch nicht allzu viel fragen ich habe
da bisher noch viel mitgemacht aber so storyboard da können wir sagen was animiert werden soll
und wir wollen ohne anime donation ich gucke gleich 3 euro vom sprat du bist angestellt
für die 3 euro 0 3 d was ist das für eine sprache das leben das ist das ist sammeln
das ist irgendwie so ein microsoft hier gespinst xml dialect und das ist die schaap aber ich
war mal ein bisschen größer und ich bin fett das ganze so storyboard und dann muss man irgendwie
so eine key muss auf fack wie ging dann das scheiß zum glück habe ich hier so ein mini spickzettel
gemacht wo ich mal nachgucken kann wie ging das denn mit mit storyboards unter unter xml hier
x key x key irgendwelche irgendwelche xml profis am start so und das ding das nennen wir als
kanal image rotation storyboard dann muss man noch angeben was man rotieren will target
name im ne ich meine ich muss es erstmal benennen image so und nun kann ich damit theoretisch
theoretisch das ding animieren aber ich brauche ich brauche was andere ich brauche storyboard
target name das habe ich schon ich brauche jetzt noch was er genau was er animieren soll
das brauche ich das ding krempel katze was ist ich brauche hier irgendwie sowas also
so weit ich das im kopf habe ist das so ich habe jetzt bild ich habe ihm gesagt was ich
für ein bild einblenden will und jetzt kann ich ihm sagen welcher dieser eigenschaften
als sowas hier wie wie höhe weiter winkel und sowas ich quasi in welcher zeit quasi
linear geändert haben will das muss man nur mal die richtige sonntags rauskriegen wieso
nimmst du dich einfach winforms weil das mit winforms nicht funktioniert rhetorische
pause winforms und transparenz beziehungsweise transparenz auf window auf window level ist
scheiße es funktioniert es funktioniert aber du hast nur probleme damit zum beispiel dass
hier diese anti alias render haben dann halt eine scheiß farbe und so das ist das ist
das ist das ist das ist das ist der übliche microsoft wahnsinn ja ich meine diese funktion
hier dass man ein fenster ein fenster schütteln dass alle anderen fenster minimiert werden
das ist ja ganz nett gedacht aber es man könnte ja in weiser voraussicht ja da kommt auch
in nadela oder wie er heißt auf die idee dass es vielleicht nicht jedem gefällt also warum
gibt es nicht einfach in den windows der tings eine option um den scheiß auszuschalten das
ist das ist so typische microsoft kacke das nervt mich immer ok lassen wir kurz konzentrieren
wie geht denn das scheiß jetzt storyboard also ich will mein image will ich werte ändern
und zwar von null bis zu 360 weil ich meine ich will ja im kreis drehen und zwar im abstand
von 2 sekunden das bedeutet dass wenn ich jetzt so storyboard target property ist in
dem fall dann image oh fuck stimmt das ich muss mal nachgucken ich habe mir nämlich
so die wichtigsten sachen so spickzettel aufgeschrieben weil ich das z.b. das pack sammel und so nicht
merken kann das da brauche ich gerade ist das kompliziert xml so genau ich sag ich will
ich will die den winkel will ich rotate in der abstand von den sekunden ja ok ich kopiere
mir das einfach was ich hier was ich hier vorher schon mal gemacht habe easy da weiß
ich dass das geht jetzt schreckt so jetzt sollte das ganze zumindest noch kompilieren
und wie ich letztens wieder von einem unserer azubis gelernt habe wenn es kompiliert dann
funktioniert es gut jetzt äh rechter maus button wenn ich den rechten maus button drücke
dann will ich dass das bild rotiert gucken ob wir das ob wir das gebacken kriegen ok
also das heißt wir müssen uns jetzt erst mal aus den rest aus den aus den resources irgendwie
das storyboard holen übrigens also falls einer da ist der schön wp auskennt und ich
mache das falsch könnte mir könnte mir das gerne schreiben da nicht so großartig viel
plan von so das heißt wir brauchen jetzt resources resources und dann den namen von von von meiner
animation das so und dann kann man hier irgendwie sagen start beginn ach nee ich muss das noch
casten auf storyboard ist natürlich nicht importieren den ganzen scheiß importieren
so und jetzt kann ich sagen storyboard beginn und wenn ich das richtig gemacht habe dann
dreht sich jetzt das bild wenn ich rechts drauf drücke dreht sich aber nicht warum
dreht sich das nicht was habe ich was habe ich denn falsch gemacht
weil ich irgendwas irgendwas ist doch hier verkehrt copy paste mir das einfach mal was
ich vorher schon mal ausprobiert habe es rotiert nicht aber es move das ist schon mal gut arrows
gibt es nicht dieses ganze wpf krempel der jax ist auch da bis wieder daheim ich weiß
was ich vergessen habe ich weiß was ich vergessen habe ich muss ihm ich muss ihm den startwinkel
sagen bei diesem image wo er anfangen soll das funktioniert nicht passt mal auf jetzt
geht's okay vielleicht noch nicht so ganz wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe okay das
funktioniert nicht so ganz wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe ich gesagt aber es dreht
sich schon mal okay ich habe ich weiß sogar woran das liegt dass es nicht funktioniert
und zwar denn im standardmäßig die linke obere ecke zum rotieren also wisst ihr wie
ich meine wenn ich wenn ich wenn der rotiert also der startet bei einem winkel von null
also sprich so und dann sagt er ihm hier in der animats was macht meine katze denn katze
was machst du da katze was machst du da was gibt das sonst fertig ist was ist okay und
ich muss ihm sagen richtig patrick genau ich muss ihm sagen wo die wo der punkt ist um
den er rotieren soll und das geht das geht folgendermaßen gut dass ich mir das vorher
schon mal ein bisschen ein bisschen gecheatet habe ein bisschen vorher was gebastelt habe
wer kommt denn auf sowas das wusste wissen oder was verloren und jetzt kann man ihm sagen
dass er prozentual in der mitte starten soll und nachdem es sammeln microsoft dialect ist
kann man die nullen weglassen oder muss man sogar die nullen weglassen ich weiß nicht
wer sich das bei microsoft ausgedacht hat es ist mir entzieht sich vollkommen meinem
guckt bäm es rotiert um die mitte krasse scheiß
aber es funktioniert und es kriegst ja guck mal deswegen meint ich es ist lustig wenn
es links rum rotiert da kann man nämlich kann ich das so einplanen da kann ich sagen
wenn man dann lacht kann man dann so machen das sieht so aus als lacht dann noch ein bisschen
mehr dabei so ok also die grundlegenden sachen funktionieren
ich fand es vorher besser ja weg dass man könnte es ja theoretisch sogar je nach bild
machen ok weiter ich würde mal sagen mehr brauchen wir eigentlich kein xml basteln
genug augenkrebs wir machen jetzt wir machen jetzt zwar hier im code weiter der war der
wahre der wahre wpf wp sonst was pro wird natürlich alles irgendwie machen so das heißt
wir können das ding jetzt per rechts klick starten zu rotieren leider per links klick
noch nicht richtig oder per weiteren rechts nicht richtig stoppen und wir können es verschieben
und wenn man es verschiebt ruckelts 2 fps lull also lil quasi aber das funktioniert schon
mal wir gucken mal wie das mit einem anderen bild aussieht wir haben ja hier noch confused
haben wir noch am start gucken wir mal wir haben ein paar zeilenobbrüche rein dass man
das ganze noch erkennt
konfuset
ok das funktioniert auch aber das ist ein doofes das ist eine blöde variante von dem
das da muss da muss man sowas anderes finden klein ok weiter gehts nachdem ich diese storyboard
garantiert noch öfters brauche machen wir uns das mal als als klassenvariable irgendwie
oben hin sorry boards ich kürze es einfach mit sb ab get benutzen wir mal c sharp 7 feature
übrigens wie gesagt leute falls ihr was übersehen habt sagt bescheid
ob's habe ich irgendwas vergessen was was meckert da compiler fehler ich habe irgendwelche
irgendwo habe ich sonntags fehler gefahr hier oder
moment wo wo habe ich was übersehen public storyboard
man braucht das gett nicht mehr man braucht das gett nicht mehr dann geht das auch so
geht das wie ging der scheiß noch mal
ach wenn es kaste ich da hinten dass das auch beknackt bist du ja jetzt gehts jetzt
jetzt funktioniert es
alles gut
wenn man Mist schreibt, schreibt man Mist
der Getcode muss um
Getplog sein
ne das ist neue
Special C sharp 7 Feature
das darf man jetzt so schreiben
die kurze Variante
ok
es funktioniert wahrscheinlich immer noch alles
ja
so, das heißt als nächstes kümmern wir uns mal
um
ich würde sagen
Rotation starten und Rotation stoppen
ähm, machen wir das mal private
also
Rotation starten stoppen
das heißt wir müssen uns auf jeden Fall merken
ob das Ding rotiert oder nicht
mach es ein E3 Stream
ja morgen wenn es losgeht, mit EA geht es los
20 Uhr
wir merken uns jetzt so was wie
is
rotating
wie ist denn
wie ist jetzt
die Microsoft
wie sagt Microsoft nochmal, dass man das schreiben muss
so ne, is rotating
glaube ich wollen die, dass man das schreibt
ist natürlich false
was sonst, wobei das defaultmäßig auch schon
false ist
ok
das heißt wir merken uns jetzt ob wir schon mal geklickt haben
und es rotiert und wenn es
nicht rotiert, dann ist der nächste Klick
mit der rechten Maustaste ein Stopp
das ist eigentlich relativ simpel
das heißt wir gucken jetzt
if rotating
dann sagen wir
rotating stopp
und vorher sagen wir ihm
dass er aufhören soll zu
rotaten, das ist eigentlich relativ simpel
so und dann
wenn es nicht rotiert, sagen wir ihm
er soll
er soll beginnen
und er soll
sich merken
dass es rotiert
gucken ob das funktioniert
also rechter Maustaste sollte jetzt
einmal starten und stoppen
ok das geht
starten, stoppen, starten, stoppen
man kann immer noch so dieses
irgendwie so ne blöde Lachanimation machen
ok das funktioniert
wir machen nochmal was
dass ich das nicht immer verschieben muss
wir sagen irgendwie
window style
ne
style
ich hab keine style
maximal
fuck ich weiß nicht wie das funktioniert
wie kann man eben sagen
dass er Fenster maximieren soll
window, irgendwas, es muss was
es muss was mit Windows sein
window state
window state maximized
sound scheint mir gerade
ein bisschen laut zu sein
ne passt, ist gut
so das heißt jetzt ist es auch immer schön
zentriert in der Mitte, so muss ich das nicht
jedes mal zentrieren
sehr schön
ich bin ja mal echt gespannt was die morgen auf
bei ihr zeigen
und vor allem
wie viel heiße Luft ist
wenn ich mir überlege
der vergleicht
das reveal
von Black Ops 4
zum reveal von Battlefield 5
letztendlich glaube ich dass mir
wenn ich es mir holen werde
wahrscheinlich Battlefield 5 deutlich mehr Spaß machen wird
es sei denn der Battle Royale Modus
vom neuen Code wird mich umhauen oder so
aber die Präsentation fand ich
von Black Ops 4 so viel angenehmer
zu gucken als von Battlefield 5
das kann ich euch gerade vorstellen
das war so ein Gelaber
das war
so ein dummes Geschwätze
die ganze Zeit
most, was
realistic war simulation
ja klar weil Battle, weil
Leute die Battlefield spielen auch echt
einen Krieg wollen, das ist total bescheuert
was schreibt der Yoshi
für customization und so und schon
möchte ich noch folgendes einreichen
Animationsvorstand von rechten Rand bis man alles
sieht reinfahren lassen, dann wieder zurückfahren
komm mal machen
ich muss jetzt aber erstmal das ein- und ausplanten hinkriegen
also so basic ist ja alles gut
wir können was einplanten sollen, jetzt müssen wir nur noch hinkriegen
dass das ganze
wechselt
das heißt wir müssen jetzt
Hotkeys definieren
nachdem ich nicht weiß wie das unter Windows geht
und auch ehrlich gesagt
das jetzt nicht rauskriegen will
noch auf den letzten Drücker
gucken wir mal was es so für
Hotkey Libraries gibt
gibt es nämlich bestimmt welche
Hotkeys
gucken wir mal was es so gibt
also man kann
vieles schlechtes
über Windows und Microsoft sagen
aber eins
muss man ihnen lassen
von allen Entwicklungsumgebungen
Visual Studio ist mit Abstand
mit Abstand
die beste
es gibt nichts was da auch nur ansatzweise rankommt
für keine Sprache
meiner Ansicht nach
auch wenn ich sonst
normalerweise auch vor allem auf der Arbeit
quasi gar nicht unter Windows unterwegs bin
aber Visual Studio ist wirklich top
da kann man nichts sagen
da kann Eclipse einpacken
was ja das kriegste
kriegt man Anfälle
da kann auch das
auch meiner Meinung nach das ganze Jetprane Zeug
einpacken
da kann eigentlich alles einpacken
das ist mir einfach das beste
am besten ist wenn man
wobei früher hat Resharper das
übelst langsam gemacht
wenn man noch ein paar Jetprane Geschichten dazu installiert
aber ich finde
insgesamt das komplette Paket ist aus
Visual Studio mit Abstand das beste
Global Hotkeys, das klingt doch gut
so was wollen wir haben
genau das wollen wir haben
gucken wir uns mal an was die für Beispiele
auf der GitHub Seite haben
10 Sterne ist nicht so der Wahnsinn
aber ist aktuell, das ist erstmal das wichtigste
das kann ich euch nur als Tipp geben
wenn man ein Library sucht
neben welche die aktuell sind
weil wenn es irgendwelche Probleme gibt
und das andere Ding oder irgendwas wissen wollt
oder im Zweifelsfall
irgendwie was findet was kaputt ist
wenn ihr irgendwas habt was 2014
das letzte Mal aktualisiert wurde habt ihr gelitten
da könnt ihr das zwar patchen
wenn man es kann
je nachdem was das für eine Sprache ist
wie komplex das ganze ist
aber du wirst es nie irgendwo rein kriegen
letztes update 2014
sucht euch immer irgendwas aktuelles
wenn es nicht gerade anders geht
jetzt brauchen wir mal ein paar Beispiele
wie man hier Hotkeys definiert
Hotkey Constructor
Hotkey Modifier Keys
kopieren wir uns doch mal das Beispiel
kopieren wir uns mal das Beispiel
und das ganze machen wir
im FormLoaded Event
falls es sowas in
WPF gibt
Loaded
Loaded wird automatisch aufgerufen
sobald das Ding vollständig gestartet ist
importieren
habe importiert
formatieren wir das mal anständig
das machen wir definitiv nicht so
wie der hier das macht
das ist der oldschool way
das macht man immer so
sondern man sagt jetzt
Parameter ist mir wurscht
Lambda
und zwar rufen wir da eine
Funktion auf
die
uns die Bilder wechselt
so
wobei wir lassen mal kurz das Beispiel
und gucken ob das mit der Messagebox
funktioniert was er hier gemacht hat
wir gucken ob das mit der Messagebox
funktioniert also wenn das mit
dem Hotkey registrieren
funktioniert
das sind bisschen viele Klammern oder
Moment
Klammer zu
ja
ok
das ist das offizielle Beispiel
was ich von ihm kopiert habe
warum geht denn
nicht mal das
offizielle Beispiel das ist ja
das ist doof wobei doch das Beispiel geht
ich habe es einfach nur kaputt oder
ach oh man
ich habe es nicht importiert
ich habe gedacht
Visual Studio macht das richtige
standardmäßig
ich habe es ja nicht mal
installiert bin ich bescheuert
warum
warum kann ich
warum kann ich denn hier nichts installieren
hä
Moment
jetzt bin ich verwirrt Leute
HiBeloTV
warum kann ich denn hier nichts installieren
Hallo
ah
ja
wer soll da auch drauf kommen
dass ich für das aktuelle Projekt
an dem ich gerade arme Sachen installieren will
warum ist das denn nicht die fault
egal ich jetzt pass alles gut
install
ja
fetzen Randy
genauso ist es
Visual Studio ist das beste was es gibt
ist das beste was es gibt
IDE ist das beste was es gibt
BDO Notification Tool irgendwann
wenn ich mal wieder BDO spiele
aber das fertig
jetzt funktioniert es wahrscheinlich auch was ich hier mache
ja jetzt klappt das ganze
ok
machen wir das mal ordentlich
dass man hier was erkennt
zack, zack, zack
zack, zack
zack
ok
so jetzt gucken wir mal ob das mit der
Messagebox funktioniert
wir machen mal einen simple
Shortcut
CTRL
CTRL L
das ist glaube ich noch nicht belegt
oder zumindest nicht global
also wenn ich jetzt CTRL L drücke
sollte eine Messagebox aufgehen
BAM passt
und die sollte auch aufgehen wenn ich nicht in dem Programm drinne bin
was nicht funktioniert
wahrscheinlich weil die Taskbar
irgendwie CTRL L gekrappt hat
hä
ach ne
weil die schon auf ist
ok passt, funktioniert
also dass es mit den Hotkeys klappt das ist schon mal schön
ähm
und CTRL L für LUL ist doch auch gut
ok wir machen das jetzt hier natürlich ein bisschen
moderner und zwar sagen wir hier
uns
wir wollen
ne
wir wollen ne Methode aufrufen
die uns halt unsere
Memebilder durchswitcht also machen wir hier so was wie
ähm
Change Swim
irgendwie so was
und dazu brauchen wir natürlich vorher
ne Liste
mit Memes die wir so haben
so
das heißt
was, was werden wir denn da für Dinge einfügen
LUL
MonkaS
Confused
ähm
PogChamp
Poggers
also es bringt nichts wenn ich so viel mache
ich muss die ja während dem Livestream auch starten können
oh mega LUL
so ist jetzt erstmal egal das ist jetzt nur ein Beispiel
so
ich muss mich auf ne neue Tastatur gewöhnen
Dischanged Meme
der kriegt nen Enum
übergeben
und dann sagen wir ihm leg mir das
mal an
sollte er das nicht
automatisch machen
hallo
also ich kann das jetzt von Hand anlegen
aber ich hätte eigentlich gedacht
Studio kann mir da was anlegen automatisch
ja hier bei
oh
Privat
Privat VWO ja
beste Idee die es gibt
ja ja jetzt macht euch nur drüber lustig
es ist die beste Idee die es gibt
so
Syntax Error
wat
oh mein vor hab ich mich jetzt hier vertippt
da kommt natürlich kein Typ
davor
ja
der fettste Mani ist auf Zack hier da ist
der schreibt das immer fast zum gleichen
Zeitpunkt wo ich das
hat er schon was geschrieben
so was hat er jetzt für Schmerzen
wahrscheinlich stimmt der Typ hier vorne nicht
ja gut
der übergibt mir höchst
wahrscheinlich den Key
aber
das ist mir eigentlich egal
so machen wir mal hier
L ist LUL
Key interessiert mich nicht
ok das funktioniert
kompiliert muss funktionieren
ist der Livestream heute oder ist es Vorbereitung
der Livestream ist morgen 20 Uhr
heute basteln wir bloß ein Tool das wir dann
passende Bilder einblenden können im Livestream
weil sowas irgendwie nicht gibt
ich lade das dann auch auf GitHub hoch
benutzt du Visual Studio Code
ja benutze ich allerdings nicht
für C Sharp
Visual Studio Code benutze ich
für
für Rust habe ich schon mal benutzt
an sich finde ich es gut aber ich habe wenig Anwendungszwecke
auf der Arbeit verwende ich
eigentlich hauptsächlich Vim weil halt
Konsole und dann Editor in der Konsole haben
ist halt sehr praktisch
vor allem wenn du auf einem Server drauf bist
dann hast du halt nicht viel GUI
das ist gar keine GUI
Visual Studio Code
also unter Linux für C Sharp ist das
auch praktisch besser als MonoDevelop
für JavaScript ist es gut
für JavaScript und TypeScript dafür ist wirklich Studio richtig gut
von der Idee her sollte der ganze Cremple jetzt
eigentlich funktionieren
Scheiß hier vorne brauchen wir nicht
kann man das irgendwie mal ordentlich formatieren
ne
aber ist ordentlich formatiert
wir machen jetzt ein Hotkey
für Ctrl L und
warum formatiert das nicht ordentlich
was ist das
sogar mal nicht die beste Idee
warum formatiert das nicht ordentlich
habe ich irgendwo
was vergessen
ich habe nichts vergessen
ok
wir machen jetzt mal
Ctrl L für LOL
und Ctrl M
für MonkaS
das heißt
ich kriege das jetzt hier reingeschwissen
jetzt den Switch rein
wir speichern uns das mal irgendwie
das speichern wir uns hier oben
das speichern wir uns in einer Variable
und zwar sowas wie
Current Leap oder sowas
irgendwie so
so
ja
das ist eigentlich voll kaputt
mit was man anfangen soll
so
und dann sagen wir jetzt Switch
so man kann ihm doch irgendwie sagen
dass er alles hinzufügen soll genau
wir machen jetzt mal nur LOL
und MonkaS wir haben ja nicht definiert
ok
das heißt wenn
der jeweilige
Shortcut gedrückt wird
dann ändern wir einfach
die Datei die das Bild
das Bild was angezeigt werden soll
so das heißt jetzt müssen wir irgendwie sagen
ja gut wir müssen jetzt die Dateien angeben wo man
wo das Zeug liegt
so das heißt hier
Image Source
so und jetzt muss ich nachgucken
weil in Windows Forms war das
noch total einfach ja Filename
sonst war das Image File überhaupt kein Ding
in WPF haben sie sich gedacht
wir machen das ganze super kompliziert und zwar
muss man jetzt sagen New Bitmap
Image und das
hat auch nie nichts irgendwie From File
oder sowas also man kann jetzt
glaube ich hier nicht sagen
also
wir nehmen jetzt hier
LOL
ich glaube zumindest nicht dass das geht
also wir nehmen jetzt hier nicht sowas
oh man ich treffe
auf der neuen Tastatur noch nicht die Tasten
das geht hier nämlich nicht
oder geht das doch
ach wisst ihr wenn man das richtig
macht
ne das geht natürlich nicht
weil Cannot Convert String to Uri
wer hätte das gedacht
deswegen muss man jetzt sowas hier draus machen
vielleicht geht das auch irgendwie einfacher
ich weiß nicht so muss ich von Hand das sagen
SgtMixer ich glaube das ist wurscht
ich glaube Windows Dateienamen
sind nicht case sensitive
also ich glaube
dass MonkaSPNG
das gleiche ist
wie
MonkaSPNG
was hast du für ne Tastatur
ich hab gerade die hier am Start
so
ok ist das jetzt von der Idee her richtig was ich gemacht hab
wenn LOL
gedrückt wird also Steuerung L dann wollen wir
Image Source auf
TotalBiscuits setzen
wenn
Ctrl M
von MonkaS gedrückt wird
dann wollen wir es auf
MonkaS setzen
das probieren wir jetzt mal aus
ob ich das richtig gemacht hab
M L BÄM funktioniert
so wunderbar
also im Prinzip
ist das ja eigentlich fast alles was wir wollen
wir wollen im Stream quasi sagen können
Bild einblenden
irgendein doofes Meme anzeigen
um schon wieder ausblenden können
das wieder ausblenden können müssen wir jetzt noch machen
also wie gesagt
wir haben dann 150 Zeichen
das reicht
und wir müssen halt noch Bilder
herunterladen und das alles einfügen
Resident Sleeper
den brauch ich auf jeden Fall noch
aber ihr seht schon man kann gar nicht so viel leben
und ihr seht
ich machs überhaupt nicht konfigurierbar
ne das kann auch keine GIF Emotes
leider nicht haben wir am Anfang ausprobiert
ihr sehts euch machs ja null konfigurierbar
also es gibt keinen Dialog oder keine Konfig Datei
wo man das irgendwie ändern könnte oder so
das ist rein
gerade noch für mich zum
Zeug anzeigen im Stream
aber man sieht hier schon
je nachdem wieviel ich hier einfüge
mir gehen ja irgendwie die Shortcuts aus
die ich mir merken kann
also ich kann mir vielleicht 7-8 Shortcuts merken
wenn sie einleuchten sind so wie Strg L für null
aber dann hört es auf
oder ich machs auf die Makro Tasten
dann müsste ich mir irgendwie die Makro Tasten merken
da hab ich aber auch bloß 6 Stück
GIF Emotes gucken wir dann mal
ob wir das hinkriegen
sonst hätten wir null 3D gemacht
ok
das können wir mal
in eine Zeile machen
oder so
eins egal wie
gibt es in Visual Studio sowas
dass man Zeilen zusammenführen kann
und quasi alle Widespaces dazwischen löschen
gibt es da eigentlich den Shortcut für
den brauchen wir natürlich auch noch
den brauchen wir auch noch
da müssen wir doch noch irgendwie gucken
wie wir animierte GIFs hinkriegen
Melolix fragt
eine sehr dumme Frage
kannst du nicht einfach eine Szene von OBS erstellen
mit den jeweiligen Memes
ist das denn nicht dasselbe denke ich mal
nee es ist nicht dasselbe das kann ich machen
du kannst dem OBS ja sogar Shortcuts irgendwo
irgendwo kann man Shortcuts definieren
für Anzeigen von Elementen
also das würde prinzipiell genau das machen was man will
aber dann sehe ich es nicht
so und jetzt überlegt euch mal
ich blende jetzt hier
keine Ahnung ich hätte Shortcuts im OBS
und ich blende jetzt einfach mal null ein
und ich sehe das nicht
und ich vergesse es wieder auszublenden
dann habt ihr eine halbe Stunde null
am Start wisst ihr
und ich sehe es halt nicht
ja klar ich kann mir einen zweiten Monitor hinstellen
habe ich ja hier am zweiten Bildschirm
wo ich es dann sehe aber ich will ja eigentlich Livestream gucken
zwischen ein paar sinnlose Memes
einblenden und dann wieder das zu machen
und es ist halt auch nicht schwierig
es ist ja mehr oder weniger schon fast fertig der ganze Kram hier
wir müssen jetzt ein paar Memes runterladen
rein und ich muss jetzt noch
jetzt würde ich noch programmieren dass das
ähm
dass ich es wieder ausblenden kann
das war's
so wir setzen hier unten jetzt nochmal
das Current Meme
und setzen wir auf das was hier
übergeben wurde
ich muss dann noch so was wie minimieren oder so
rein machen dass ich es wieder ausblenden kann
ok gucken wir mal
aber das ganze Ding jetzt mal fertig
also ich brauche hier
so was wie
also ich will
wie will ich, wie mache ich denn das jetzt
am besten wie blende ich
das ganze wieder aus ich würde sagen indem ich
einfach das Meme was angezeigt wird
nochmal den Shortcut drücke
dann blende das aus
und wenn ich wieder
einfach so Toggle halt
einmal drücken einblenden
zweites mal drücken ausblenden
kannst du den Stream nicht
durch dein OBS Fenster gucken
doch das würde funktionieren aber das ist mir
zu noob style
das will ich nicht
außerdem ist es doch mal ein guter
anlass mal wieder ein Programmier Stream zu machen oder
so
das heißt ich muss jetzt erstmal gucken
ist oder
ok also wir gucken jetzt mal
ist das Fenster
maximiert
wenn das
wenn das Fenster maximiert ist
habe ich das jetzt falsch gesagt
ach es ist Windows State
warum haben die das auch so
gleichgekannt Windows State
wenn es maximiert ist
und
das Current Meme gleich dem
ist wo ich den Shortcut
für gedrückt habe
dann will ich es ausblenden
dann sagen wir
Window State gleich
minimized
gucken wir mal ob das funktioniert jetzt schon mal
ne das lassen wir erstmal weg
weil das funktioniert erstmal so nicht
das funktioniert
ok das minimieren klappt schon mal gut
ne ne ne ne ne
ein eigener Luleffekt kann ich in WPF nicht bauen
ich glaube auch nicht dass es das kann
so ohne weiteres
ok es minimiert das ganze
so das heißt wenn das
minimiert ist
ist gut dann wollen wir aufhören
dann machen wir nichts
wenn der State
quasi nicht
maximized ist
dann
switchen wir zum jeweilig gedrückten Meme
und
ähm planten
das ganze ein
das müsste
das müsste eigentlich
das müsste es eigentlich schon sein
gucken
ja funktioniert
und das ist eigentlich alles was ich haben will
das ist alles was ich haben will
wer will ich nicht haben
wenn ich rechts klick
wird
wird im Kreis gelullt
oder aber
im Kreis gemonka est
das ist alles mehr will ich nicht haben
wir sind mehr oder weniger schon fertig
ne MrFryger das geht nicht
der kann auch keine Gifts
anzeigen
also jetzt müssen wir im Prinzip
nur noch Memes runterladen
und unter dem richtigen Namen
speichern und es funktioniert
habe ich irgendwas
vergessen
wir könnten
das drehen
auch stoppen
wir stoppen das drehen
immer beim meme switch
also das heißt wenn ich jetzt
lull anfange zu drehen und switch dann auf monka
es dann aufzudrehen
ja das ist ganz praktisch
sonst habe ich einmal drehen an und dann
so ist besser
magst du die memes wirklich so riesig drüberballen
ich habe mir das so gedacht
wir gucken uns den stream an
und wenn etwas lustiges passiert mache ich so
dann mache ich wieder aus
also wisst ihr das ist nicht so dass ich die ganze Zeit anlasse
wenn er jetzt irgendwie
wenn er erzählt dass sie so sorry sind wegen
battlefront 2
oder dass sie die besten Fans haben
ihre fans hören und die most dedicated
fanbase und sowas dann mache ich halt
so fertig
weiter gehts irgendwie sowas
und
mehr solls ja auch nicht machen
omega null geht
noch nicht das können wir aber jetzt machen
da müssen wir aber erstmal ein transparentes
bild für finden
ist nicht transparent
transparent
das ist
es gibt kein
es gibt kein omega null
es gibt kein transparentes omega null
und jetzt
was mache ich jetzt
Leute
ich brauche ein transparentes omega null
frei
ne
wobei
ich habe
ich habe kein bock jetzt
bild bearbeitungs
kram zu machen muss es muss der
omega null auch geben als
schon freigestelltes bild
kann doch nicht sein
gucken wir mal
ne wie ging
ich glaube hier gab es
die emotes in besserer quali
schauen wir mal
ja
komm laden wir es laden wir es von hier runter
ich meine das ist zwar nicht schön
ist das überhaupt durchsichtig
ja müsste
na hoffentlich
ist das durchsichtig
ne
ne ist nicht
durchsichtig ja da können wir das auch nicht verwenden
was das
ist die durchsicht
ja wenn es nicht transparent
ist es doof
ah nice nice
weißt du der hat schon eine link geschickt
das brauchen wir
omega null
gibt es das nicht auch nochmal 4
so und das ist transparent
das ist transparent sehr schön
ok
da ist auch ein png
dann bauen wir das noch schnell ein
das heißt
ich muss jetzt gucken
dass ich keine shortcuts verwende
die ich halt so brauche
also machen wir hier mal shortcuts o
ich muss bisher irgendwie merken können
den kram also control o
wird jetzt omega
null
das heißt wir machen case
memes
omega null
und dann kopieren wir den krempel
warum hat virtual studio eigentlich noch
keine dateifahrt auto
vervollständigung
ahja
funktioniert das bild ist aber ein bisschen
bisschen schlecht aufgelöst
im vergleich zu
zu naja
kriegen wir das nicht noch ein bisschen
höher aufgelöst
meme tool was soll das sein
siehst du doch hier
kannst auf shortcuts meme bilder einplenden
transparent wohlgemerkt
und du kannst sie drehen wobei das
eher ein sinnloses gimmick ist
egal reicht
ich weiß nicht das sieht schon scheiße aus
von der quali her
aber wir haben
brauchen wir denn
brauchen wir denn null
und omega null
braucht man das
ist das notwendig dass man beides
braucht
ja
na gut
zwar klar
ok dann
brauche ich leute beispiele
dass ich das morgen im stream checke
wann verwende ich
null und wann verwende ich
dann omega null
also denkt mal an ea presse konferenz
und denkt euch mal ein beispiel aus
wann nehme ich null wann nehme ich omega null
am besten
am besten auch noch null
na null ist eh größer null
da gibt es nichts zu merken
die tastatur ich drücke immer die falschen knapp
ah es funktioniert
nur wenn ich das gleiche meme zweimal
hintereinander drücke blende das wieder aus
so soll das so soll das sein
epileptische anfälle
epilepsiewarnung achtung
ist instant omega null
ist kappa am stand
ob man kappa braucht
bei der ea presse konferenz oder bei streams
weiß ich nicht
das ist
da weiß ich so den
anlass nicht so richtig dazu
also was wir auf jeden fall
natürlich noch brauchen ist
wir brauchen jetzt erst nochmal ein ordentliches
bild hier von
von ihm hier
unfused
wir wollen kein
gif
wir wollen transparent
ok das ist transparent
aber ein bisschen klein oder
und das sieht kacke aus
so
das ist aber schon mal besser
ist schon mal besser als das andere
ok
wir belenden es erst mal um
so dann fügen wir das ganze ein
confused mache ich steuerung
wie oder so für btf
ich muss ja das ja merken können
so
die auflösung ist
echt
das stimmt
steuerung w macht das tab zu
ne das kann ich nicht machen
wenn ich da miss drücke
wobei das schön ist ich habe globale hotkeys
das heißt solange das programm läuft
kriegt mein browser
kriegt mein browser die hotkeys ja gar nicht
das heißt ich kann auch nichts falsches drücken
aber genau dafür ist es da
mehr soll das ganze überhaupt nicht machen
das funktioniert schon wunderbar
ich will einfach auf knopfdruck
einblenden können hier
und auf knopfdruck wieder ausblenden
ich kann jetzt hier
l m w o
und mit o wieder ausblenden
oder mit w wieder ausblenden
das klappt doch gut
ich brauche das ganze aber
ein bisschen bessere auflösung
eben hat jemand geschrieben man kann mir hier das omega lul
in bessere auflösung schicken
ah hier omega lul höhere
auflösung nice sehr schön
sehr schön da kriegen wir jetzt erst mal hier
ein ordentliches omega lul das ist auch
transparent ja
äh warum
war ich ja der browser das ist komplett woanders
ne das ist aber nicht
transparent
das ist nicht transparent ich brauche
ich brauche das transparent
ich brauche das transparent sonst wird das
sonst klappt das ja nicht
hab ich nicht gesagt always on top
bei dem programm so
hab ich nicht gesagt das soll
immer topmost sein
ach was auch immer
ah gut da kommt da machen wir hier
noch einen
activate
oder irgendwie sowas drunter dass da auch auf jeden
fall
auf jeden fall im vordergrund
ist
ja patrick dafür habe ich den extra streaming account
da kann ich auch nichts
leaken
omega lul transparent
perfekt
gucken wir aufs geht
ja so ist das viel besser
so ist das doch viel besser
das haben wir lul und omega lul das schöne ist
dass l und o auch so direkt
beieinander liegen
ne ist nicht die gleiche quali
das rot ist nicht so verpixelt
ok resident sleeper
brauchen wir aber auf jeden fall oder
irgendwie ein sleeper
sleeper
meme da für
das weil das ist bei
ea wird das ganz ganz akut resident
sleeper werden
ich glaub den brauchen wir bei ea nicht
auf jeden fall noch
und wenn monkaS nicht reicht
brauchen wir noch ne zweite variante von
ne brauchen wir nicht
ja
ab morgen ab 20
oder kurz vor 20
soll ich dir den confused ausschneiden
ja das wäre nicht schlecht
wenn man den confused
noch in bisschen
höhere auflösung kriegen hätte das schon
seinen charm
wenn du das
mit den gifs ja mit den gifs
ich weiß nicht gucken wir mal
wie das geht ich brauche aber erstmal
hier noch mal hier unseren resident sleeper
transparent
und einer von
eigentlich auch noch
ich überleg mir morgen
noch was was ich hier noch genau für
meme sleeper
ja ob ich die joshi ob ich die noch
reinnehme muss ich mal gucken weil
also das das das das eine finde ich
richtig passend
wiku chat wiku
command command brew
wiku
ok ich wollte ja mal gucken wpf
gif
ok
was gibt's denn da
für sachen
gif
okay
library
simple library display
animated gifs also falls
falls wir das hinkriegen mit animated
gifs dann
brauchen wir auf jeden
fall noch
0 3d und dann muss
und entweder muss dann
muss dann null oder omega null raus, weil dreimal null brauchen wir auch nicht
So wie funktioniert der kram hier
simple libel just per innen
gif, ich will es ja, wisst ihr leute
ich bin ja fan von gif, aber es gibt ja welche die müssen das alles so richtig geil ausspringen, aber gif
so java und gif und und und jit, das ist nicht git, das ist jit
da krieg ich immer ausschläge von
so animated gif
also ich finde das klingt jetzt nicht schwierig
es klingt nicht schwierig zu verwenden, mal gucken ob es das hier bei nougat gibt
wie heißt der krampe, wpf animated gif, das versuchen wir noch einzubauen, wpf animated gifs, gif, wotface, ja der muss eigentlich auch noch ein, das wird ein bisschen viel irgendwie
das wird langsam ein bisschen viel ey, den brauchen wir eigentlich auch noch
gucken wir mal, ich muss mir da morgen noch mal in ruhe gedanken drüber machen was ich jetzt genau für memes reinnehme
wpf animated gif, das ist richtig wambo, aber nachdem mit big brain ist ja bei mir nix mehr, bin da zu alt schon
ich kann mir keine 15 shortcuts merken und die dann in der sekunde auch das richtige drücken
doch ich kann das, wenn ihr wollt, also wenn ihr wollt kann ich das tool bei github hochladen, da kann es jeder verwenden, aber es hat halt null optionen, es gibt keine config datei
oder irgendwas, das heißt wenn man das anpassen will, sogar den fad wo das bild liegt, dann muss man erstmal source code editieren und kompilieren, dann kann man es verwenden
race ow, ja quasi iron aids kopieren, wpf animated gif, hauptsache geil ausgesprochen
so also wie funktioniert das jetzt sagt man, einfach einfach so hier, ok probieren wir, machen wir
case memes, was haben wir denn hier, null 3d brauchen wir dann noch, null 3d, wenn case null 3d
dann, jetzt müssen wir mal gucken wie wir das hier einbauen, dann wir nehmen jetzt einfach mal den beispielcode von dem typ, null 3d, image behavior, ok einbinden
was ist image in dem fall, wahrscheinlich das wpf element, ne, was ist image in dem fall, also image müsste in dem fall auch einfach
übrigens das muss ich umbenennen, das kann ich nicht image nennen, weil das andere schon image heißt, das heißt es ist halt image, sollen wir mal gucken ob das jetzt funktioniert
reicht es nicht wenn du den fad vom bild änderst in der source, ne, weil für gif muss ich das ja durch die library hier jagen, dass die das macht
deswegen muss ich da sonst, hier bei den oberen, siehst du ja bei den oberen ändere ich ja einfach nur den fad zur datei
MeloLinks meint ich soll mein numpad benutzen für die hotkeys, das finde ich ist eine gute idee, problem ist dann, dann kann ich mir nicht merken was 123457589 genau ist
und wenn ich erst auf den zettel gucken muss, dann ist ja der witz schon wieder vorbei, achso ja flocksix, klar das reicht, also wenn man ein wishlist studio hat, ist kein ding, kannst du machen
kannst du einfach fad ändern und kannst verwenden, vielleicht machen wir dann, vielleicht aktiviert, bisschen erweitern wird das auch noch, warum hab ich eigentlich die ganze zeit über 150 oder um die 150 zuschauer
ich hab nie so viel zuschau
den besten witz der woche, den besten witz der woche hab ich heute gesehen, da hat mir der db navigator auf twitter, äh nicht auf twitter, auf mein handy geschickt, dass der zugverspätung hat, ohne
mir anzuzeigen was, das war kompletter software fail wieder von der bahn
ich hab das bild leider nur auf dem handy drauf, aber die haben es voll verkackt
achso, ja und der zweitgrößte witz war die apple presse konferenz, der typ hat gesagt, die sind ja voll aufgedreht dabei, was hat der erzählt, deep technology accelerated workflow, da kannst du, da kann irgendwie schon
so richtig so rap god mäßig, kann da schon mal einer was drauf machen, deep accelerated workflow, also da kannst du voll was, das müsste man vielleicht mal haftbefehle oder so geben, dass er dann da immer irgendwie was draus bastelt
so die aslak version, so was, was wollte ich denn jetzt eigentlich machen, achso ich wollte gucken ob das jif funktioniert, und zwar brauchen wir da einen neuen hotkey für, wir brauchen mal den w hotkey, das war für 0.3d, mal gucken ob das jetzt, ich wäre überrascht wenn es einfach so funktioniert
nein, es kackt ab, ich seh meine exception nicht, was hab ich für ne exception, file not found, warum file not found
achso, weil es kein png ist, sondern ein jif, hab ich ja ganz vergessen, bam, in your face, funktioniert instant, das ist mal ne gute library, beispielcode, ding installiert, copy pasted, funktioniert
poggers, sage ich jetzt nur, poggers hier, oh ich kanns nicht mehr ausschalten, ja weil das muss ich noch einbauen, ich kann das bild nicht mehr switchen nachdem ich es einmal aktiviert habe, aber es funktioniert
das heißt ich muss das dann wieder rausschmeißen, wie lösche ich denn das jetzt wieder, habt ihr da irgendeine idee, also hier setze ich jetzt ja quasi als
das bild hier für meine image box, und hier setze ich es auch, aber hier setze ich es nicht über source, wie kann ich das denn jetzt wieder löschen, wie mache ich das jetzt wieder weg
kann ich hier irgendwie sagen, image behavior, so remove oder so, hallo cheesypro36, war ich denn jetzt wieder weg, einfach null, nee das funktioniert nicht
ich hab keine ahnung wie ich das wieder weg, wie mache ich das wieder weg, das animated jif
auskennen folks, das ist ne gute idee, das probieren wir mal, wir machen das jetzt einfach, das glaube ich aber nicht, dass das so funktioniert, aber gucken wir mal, wir machen das jetzt einfach mal hier im ton, dann sollte er dir einfach kein bild mehr anzeigen
das könnte tatsächlich funktionieren, ah quatsch, confuse geht ja nicht, funktioniert, krass, der auskennen fuchs, der kennt sich echt aus, der weiß, der weiß Bescheid
einfach nullen, das ist absolut untypisch, dass man irgendwas nullen muss dafür, dass es wieder, das muss man nirgendswo sonst machen, das ist voll gegen den geister der sprache, dass man dann Dinge nullen muss, die dann magic dazu führen, dass andere Dinge wieder funktionieren
das ist total bescheuert, aber ich bin froh, dass es funktioniert, deep technology accelerated workflow war das, ist visual studio for free, ja die community edition, das war ich hier verwenden, ist komplett for free
ich würd sagen wir sind fertig, was passiert denn eigentlich, das müssen wir jetzt mal ausblühen, der crashs bestimmt oder irgendwas, was passiert denn eigentlich wenn ich jetzt sage er solls drehen, fuck
mindblown, expanding brain, jetzt ist vorbeig, ich hab ja eingebaut, dass wenn man rechts klickt, dass er das bild dreht
und das in kombination mit dem ist halt schon geil, das ist null 4d, das ist hyper null 3d ist das, das wäre fast ein eigenes channel emote wert oder null 4d
vor allem da wirds dir echt schlecht bei, und jetzt stellt euch mal vor, man macht das doch irgendwie, das sah jetzt komplett aus
hyper null gibt es schon, übrigens danke für die ganzen follow us, ich muss mal nachgucken, wer ist ja jetzt alles am start
ich würd sagen programmiertechnisch macht es genau das, was ich haben will, ich lad mir morgen noch ein paar memes runter und dann überleg ich mir ein paar shortcuts, dann funktioniert das schon, gibt es noch irgendeine funktion, die man da unbedingt einbauen muss, habt ihr noch irgendeine idee, ich mein ich bin noch ein bisschen wach, das ist kein ding, können wir noch irgendwas basteln, wir müssen uns auch noch bullshit bingo für EA ausdenken
okay follow us, jede menge follow us
wen dürfen wir dann im stream begrüßen, das finde ich durf, irgendwie sieht man immer nur die letzten 10-15 follow us hier
also wir dürfen neu im stream begrüßen den Mr. Harobo1, den Mr. Harobo1, warum steht er 2x drinne, aber einer mich gehostet hat mit einem viewer, oh kreise scheiße
PogChamp
Poggers, der Trebi2, AlphaZero, Lukatin, Urinschorle, da wo wir gerade beim thema sind, wusstet ihr eigentlich, dass es 2 Kotz Emojis gibt mittlerweile
ist euch das bewusst, ja, es gibt den Emoji vorm kotzen und den Emoji beim kotzen, deswegen habe ich eigentlich drauf gehofft, dass es mit dem neuen Unicode Standard noch was dazwischen gibt
ich mein es gibt smiley quasi vorm kotzen und smiley beim kotzen, man könnte dann auch machen Emoji nach dem kotzen oder so, da ist dann blau und liegt drinne oder sowas, aber nein, haben sie nicht gemacht
Beatport, mega geil wäre eine settings page, also ich werde keine, ich werde garantiert keine UI konfiguration hier irgendwie für basteln, aber was man vielleicht machen könnte ist, dass man eine config datei angibt
dass man eine config datei angibt, was es für bilder gibt und dass er einfach die dateinamen anquasi nimmt oder dass man in der config datei quasi Shortcut plus Dateinamen angibt oder sowas
was, du kannst mit Windows Tasten plus Punkt eine Emoji übersetzen, wusste ich nicht, geht nicht, geht nicht, geht nicht, Fake News
Beatport, die gehen gerade alle ab, aber ich habe GitLab auf der Arbeit, 3 Jahre oder so hatten wir eine GitLab Installation, es war in Ordnung, aber so wahnsinnig, dass ich jetzt sagen würde, ich muss das da unbedingt
also GitHub ist mir als Plattform viel lieber als GitLab, einfach weil, das ist halt wie bei vielen Sachen, so HannahEye, es sind alle bei GitHub, das heißt du hast die meisten Projekte bei GitHub, die meisten Contributors, die meisten Leute, die sich das angucken
Schrottler, das habe ich noch nicht weiter gebastelt, das Screenshot Tool, ne also bei mir geht Windows Tasten und Punkt geht bei mir nicht, ich schwöre alter, geht nicht, Ehrenmann, geht nicht
vielleicht geht es nur in Visual Studio nicht, gucken wir mal in Firefox, vielleicht geht es da, ne geht auch nicht, geht nicht, vielleicht kann man sich hier eine Emoji Übersicht, ne geht natürlich auch nicht, das wäre ja auch mal was, dass man im Startmenü was findet, was man sucht
RGB-Integration
Die Idee ist gar nicht schlecht, ich habe mir schon überlegt, ob ich nicht, dass ich mir besser merken kann, RGB auf der Tastatur einstellen, quasi in der Farbe der Memes, also dass ich dann sagen würde, ok, den Shortcut von MonkaS mache ich grün, den für Omega Lull mache ich rot, so in der Richtung ist er, dass ich es einfacher finde
Ich habe es auf Englisch, es ist alles auf Englisch, mein Windows ist auf Englisch
Und ich habe, also Windows Version habe ich auf dem Rechner das vor dem Redstone Update, weil er das irgendwie auf diesem lustiger Weise, also ich habe alle Sicherheits Updates und sonst was, auf diesem wollte er es noch nicht machen, aber auf dem anderen hat er es schon gemacht
Im Startmenü steht überhaupt nichts auf Deutsch, Create, Play, Explore, dass er das hier auf Deutsch schreibt, da sieht man halt mal, was das für eine komische Mischung ist, die Microsoft zusammengelegt hat
Ich probiere jetzt mal auf dem zweiten Rechner Windows Punkt, es funktioniert auch nicht, muss man dafür Cortana anhaben oder irgendwas, weil ich habe alles ausgestellt, was es so gibt
Ach, das Emoji Menü ist eine Funktion von 18.03, ja so eine advancede Funktion kann man natürlich auch selbstverständlich, ist klar, es hätte mir klar sein müssen, dass ein Emoji Menü auf Shortcut natürlich nur unter dem aktuellsten brandneuesten Windows Update funktioniert
Ist klar, sowas Pleading, so eine Pleading Edge Technologie kann man einfach nicht vorher machen, jo wann geht der E3 Stream los, morgen 20 Uhr
Ja, ich scrolle jetzt mal kurz durch, weil ich irgendwie habe was überlesen
Oh, Confused 800x800, ja das ist nice, das ist nice, oh das ist sehr nice, der gefällt mir, das gefällt mir, wartet mal kurz, gleich wieder am Start
Ja, der ist gut, den müssen wir noch einbauen, den müssen wir noch einbauen
Confused, sehr schön und Confused braucht noch ein, gibt es einfach auch nur 3 als Key
Da waren wir nämlich Confused wieder mit der W
Jawoll, der ist das doch viel besser von der Auflösung her, er hat es schön freigestellt
Ja, damit kann man was anfangen, wenigstens war es eine ordentliche Auflösung, ich habe von dem linken zu unten eine ordentliche Auflösung gefunden
Und das einzige was wir jetzt noch brauchen ist ein bisschen hochauflösender Transparenten Residenz Leaper, dann haben wir alles
Eine Umfrage, welche Beams noch reingehören, naja, wie gesagt, ich bin also die Anzahl reich, das ist schon viel zu viel, das kann ich mir nicht alles merken
Ach, das funktioniert nur auf dem englischen Tasten der Art, ernsthaft jetzt, ne, funktioniert auch nicht
Ach ne, das ist German Keyboard, was ist das für eine komische, warum habe ich diese Option überhaupt
Wie stelle ich jetzt, diese neuen Windows Optionen, wo stelle ich denn jetzt die Keyboards, Leute, da seht ihr mal, soweit ist es schon
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie man das Tastaturlayout umstellt, ich weiß es schlicht und ergreifend nicht
Wie sich Max permanent unterschwellig über Windows aufregt, ich rede mich ja nicht mal unterschwellig über Windows auf
Ne, der Residenz Leaper sieht ziemlich kaputt aus, den können wir nicht nehmen
Wisst ihr, ich hättest ja was, wo man Keyboard Layout sucht oder so, dann findet man was, aber ne, nach Layout gibt es auch nichts
Wie, okay, das probieren wir jetzt aus, wie stellt man unter Windows das Tastaturlayout um, Type Settings, okay, also ich muss mal kurz in mich gehen
Also, ich bin jemand, der absolut keine Ahnung vom Computer hat, absolut Null, ich bin in der Lage, das Setting Menü aufzumachen und jetzt will ich mal den Tastaturlayout umstellen
Time and Language würde ich dann wahrscheinlich gehen oder Devices, Devices, gucken wir erstmal Devices, Typing, da würde ich wahrscheinlich als erstes gucken und für Hoffnungslos falsch
Okay, danach würde ich gucken Time and Language, Region and Language, wo kann man das Tastaturlayout umstellen
Was denkt man sich denn bei so einem, was auf Sprache klicken, ernsthaft, ne, Speech Language, ne, ne
Wieso benutzt du auch Windows 10, ganz einfach, weil das das einzige Betriebssystem ist, wo Spiele ordentlich drauf laufen, für alles andere, ernsthaft, da hab ich im Zweifelsfall meine Linux-VM
Add Language, aber ich muss doch Language nicht adden, ich hab doch schon Englisch und ich will auch kein Language pack, ich will einfach nur, einfach nur das Keyboardlayout umstellen
Das ist die alte Systemsteuerung, da geht das einfach auch nicht mehr
Add a Keyboard, also nachdem ich schonmal die quasi weltweit führende Sprache ENDE habe, also quasi was auch immer das sein soll, Englisch, Deutsch, hab ich keine Keyboards da drin
Okay, dann adden wir mal ein Keyboard, aaah, und dann wollte ich schon immer mal Englisch, India haben, weil Englisch anders da gibt's nicht, auch gut, Englisch, India, okay
Englisch, India, die Mochi-Menü geht immer auch nicht, okay
Ach die Move geht auch nicht
Microsoft, was ist das denn? Und warum gibt es hier kein Englisch-Englisch?
Na gut, das ist mein, das versteh ich, das braucht der Microsoft Support-Mitarbeiter, das geht nicht anders, Tastenkombination in einem Textfeld ausführen, okay, also hier oben drinnen, aaah, ja das muss natürlich auch einer dabei sagen, dass das nur in einem Textfeld geht
Das sind solche Sachen, mittlerweile muss ich sagen, Windows hat sich ja wirklich gemacht, das kann's ja nicht mal mit dem Schund von früher vergleichen, aber Microsoft hat einfach von Oberflächendesign absolut keine Ahnung
Und nicht nur keine Ahnung, sie ändern auch keine Ahnung laufend, sodass du heute unter Windows aus 4 bis 5 Generationen die jeweils damals gängige Microsoft-UI-Philosophie hast
Also sprich, du hast 5 Generationen keine Ahnung, aber immer wieder anders keine Ahnung, und dann hast du solche Mischungen wie dieses Menü hier, die alte Systemsteuerung, ganz alte Dialoge wie den Geräte-Manager und sowas
Was, was ist das denn? Äh ja, gut, und was mach ich jetzt mit den Emojis im Suchefenster? Was passiert noch nicht mal was, wenn man die anklickt?
Moment, man darf die nicht anklicken? Hä? Hä, ok, packt rum
Wer hat denn deiner Meinung nach Ahnung von Oberflächendesign? Tja, also ich würde sagen, Twitter? Ähm, Twitter auf jeden Fall
Amazon?
Also, von irgendwelchen Dialogs-Sachen kann ich jetzt denn wirklich anfangen, weil die meisten Sachen, die ich verwende, kann man nicht so wirklich als Oberfläche so, ich meine Terminal mit Zeug drinnen, das ist jetzt nicht so das, was sich die meisten Autografische Oberfläche vorstellen
Oder i3 als Window-Manager hat ja auch nicht wirklich viel Oberfläche
Also Twitter und Amazon würde ich auf jeden Fall sagen, Amazon allein schon rein ähm, ja quasi praktisch orientiert, die müssen, wenn die Oberfläche auf Amazon scheiße wäre, ähm, würden die Leute nichts kaufen und nichts finden
Amazon gibt sich enorm viel Mühe, dass die Leute beim Bestellvorgang, ja, in den, in den Settings, ähm, in den Settings, wenn es dann darum geht, dass man sich irgendwie seine Historie anzeigen lassen kann oder irgendwelche anderen Sachen, wird es auch bei Amazon übelst wirr, ja
Also die normale Amazon-Shop-Oberfläche, da haben die so viel Gehirngeschmalls reingesteckt, dass da auch keiner auf die Idee kommt, den Bestellvorgang abzubrechen, das merkste, ähm, wie findest du Steams Oberflächendesign, ja, finde ich gut, Steam finde ich nicht schlecht, Steam ist okay
Man merkt, man merkt Steam an, dass es ein bisschen älter ist und man merkt Steam an, dass es eigentlich auch nur ein Browser ist, das alles hier ist ein Browser, alles, es ist ein Chrome im Endeffekt
Aber ich finde es nicht schlecht, das Ingame-Overlay ist auch ein Chrome, das einzige was halt kein Chrome ist, ist wahrscheinlich FPS-Anzeigen und sowas
Ich finde es nicht schlecht, ich finde es nicht schlecht, also wenn man sich bei Steam dran gewöhnt hat, was ich, was ich bei Steam gut finde ist, dass es, dass es relativ einheitlich ist
Zumindest für die Standardsachen, zum Beispiel, wenn ich jetzt auf das Game gehe, weiß ich, es gibt auf der rechten Seite einen Link, genau, einen Link zum Diskussionsforum
Und wenn ich im Diskussionsforum bin, bin ich quasi direkt auf der, auf dieser Content-Seite dafür und hab dann irgendwelche Guides und sonst was, das ist schon nicht schlecht
Ja, Twitter auch
Twitter, Twitter finde ich hat seit Jahren eigentlich eines der besten Webseiten, die auch wesentlich reduziert ist und einfach macht, was sie soll
Und Twitter hat es bisher geschafft, trotz UI-Updates, dass immer, als quasi die Leute nicht vor, nicht vor den Kopf zu stoßen, so wie das Snapchat zum Beispiel gemacht hat
Das habt ihr wahrscheinlich mitgekriegt
Ich verwende, ich verwende kein Snapchat, aber das haben wahrscheinlich, denke ich war die meisten mitgekriegt, die haben ja dann ein Update gemacht, was quasi der Snapchat-Chef mehr oder weniger im Alleingang durchgedrückt hat
Und danach haben glaube ich 3 Millionen Leute oder so eine Petition unterzeichnet, oder waren es noch mehr, es waren massiv viele Leute, ja nicht nur die 8, es waren viel mehr
Und jetzt haben sie wieder das alte UI am Start
So, lass mal überlegen, was gibt es denn noch für gute Oberflächen, wo ich sagen würde, also jetzt nicht nur von einzelnen Programmen, sondern wo ich sagen würde, die sind wirklich, die sind wirklich gut durchdacht
Weil einzelne Programme fallen mir da zwar ein, aber Discord, ja Discord, Discord ist auch gut, Discord ist gut, ja Discord, ja finde ich auch
Discord ist gut, aber ja, wo wir gerade, ja jetzt fallen wir noch mehr an, links hier, das finde ich auch super, Media Center
Das ist zwar in den Settings her teilweise ein bisschen verwirrend, aber wenn man sich einen ordentlichen Skin für nimmt, kann das jeder bedienen, das ist halt auch eine gute Oberfläche
Moin, The Barp
Ja, was gibt es da noch so für Software, wo ich sage, ja Dings hier, was auch geil ist, auch eine super Oberfläche, das ist eigentlich der Grund, warum ich es mir gekauft habe, ihr wisst, ich bin ja nicht so der, so der Bildbearbeitungsmensch
Aber, nein wir wollen jetzt keine neue Version haben, aber Affinity Designer und Affinity Photo oder wie das andere heißt, ich hatte das hier noch nie gestartet, ist eine, ist ein super Programm, das ist, das ist klar, ja, da kann sogar ich mit Thumbnails machen
Und es ist saumäßig schnell, Saito, ja, ist klar, ist klar, Elektron Master Race, ja, Elektron ist die Ausgeburt des Web Shits, außer Discord, ja, nehmen wir mal außen vor, es ist auch Elektron, aber Elektron ist wirklich die Ausgeburt des Web Shits
YouTube hat kein gutes, keine gute, generell hat Google fast nirgendwo gute Oberflächen, das meiste auf Android finde ich auch nicht gut gemacht
Das meiste auf IOS finde ich, geht eigentlich, das ist wenigstens einheitlich, das ist nicht unbedingt schöner, ja, aber ich schluss für die Core, das ist auch Elektron, ja
Android finde ich an sich grausam, ich meine, ich hab zwar viele Android Geräte, aber das User Interface, das finde ich schrecklich, was sie sich da ausgedacht haben
Das fängt schon an mit wischen von unten, wischen von oben, Hersteller, die das dann teilweise merken, so ASUS customise die Dinger ganz komisch, dass man den WLAN Settings nicht sieht, was das WLAN für eine, gibt viele Sachen, es sind oftmals so Kleinigkeiten, wo ich mir denke, warum ist das so
Oder dass die YouTube App, ich meine, wir haben das Jahr 2018, jeder Hinterweltler Media Player, also den schlechtesten, billigsten, zusammengeschustesten Media Player, den du findest für ein Smartphone, kann im Hintergrund was abspielen
Aber dreimal dürft ihr raten, was kann, welche App kann im Hintergrund nichts abspielen, oh, welche App kann nichts im Hintergrund abspielen, so der Marktführer, quasi in diesem Bereich, wer kann das nicht, genau, YouTube kann das nicht
Und wenn man sich fragt, warum, klar, ich weiß, warum sie, also man kann sagen, ja, das ist weil YouTube Red und mit YouTube Red kann sie das, aber eine Basisfunktion im Hintergrund abspielen, Leute, dafür Geld zu verlangen, das ist nicht dreist, das ist eigentlich nicht von dieser Welt im Kopf irgendwie
Ich meine, wie schlecht muss ein Service sein, dass man quasi das Verkaufsargument bringt, ja, du kannst im Hintergrund abspielen, das heißt, ist das Service so beschissen, dass YouTube Red nichts zu bieten hat, außer, dass man offiziell die Sachen im Hintergrund abspielen kann, ist das so schlecht, das Service oder was
Was, welches Bildbearbeitungsprogramm hast du gerade gezeigt, das ist Affinity Designer, das ist gut
Ja, das, wo wir bei gutem UI sind, bei Twitch kann man sich darüber streiten, also Twitch im Browser, muss ich sagen, finde ich es nicht schlecht, also es ist fokussiert auf den Inhalt, du findest die Sachen eigentlich relativ schnell
Also bei Twitch kannst du dich im Browser nicht beschweren, sie haben manche Sachen verschlimmbessert, ja, dass sie jetzt hier dieses Dropdown gemacht haben seit einer Weile, anstatt die Communities oben drin stehen zu haben, ok
Was sie bei Twitch überhaupt nicht hingekriegt haben, ist die neue Smartphone App, unter Android hast du glücklicherweise ein paar Alternativen, anstatt die offizielle Twitch App, unter iOS hast du nichts, da musst du mit der kack Twitch App leben
Die Twitch App ist kacke, Twitch im Browser finde ich gut, was gibt es noch für Programme, die gut sind, OBS ist hässlich, aber OBS finde ich vom Ansatz her auch gut, also OBS ist wirklich kein schönes Programm
Ich meine, man muss OBS auch zugute halten, es ist Multiplattform, die Oberfläche ist glaube ich in Qt 5 programmiert, also von OBS, aber die Optionen sind in der Regel da, wo man sie vermutet und es ist super simpel zu verwenden
Es hat schon seinen Grund, warum kein Mensch mehr Xsplit oder Wirecast oder wie das andere Zeug hieß, verwenden, es verwenden eigentlich alle OBS, das hat seinen Grund, und das ist auch gut so, VLC, na VLC finde ich, VLC hat keine gute Oberfläche
VLC ist wir, VLC weiß ich nicht, wo du was finden musst, Spotify geht so, Spotify finde ich jetzt weder sonderlich gut, noch sonderlich schlecht, das macht was es soll, wie gesagt Schießnudel Amazon finde ich hat auch eine gute Oberfläche
Was soll mein Programm eigentlich machen, mein Programm ist schon fertig, das zeigt transparente Memes an und kann per Shortcut umgeschaltet werden auf unterschiedliche Memes und weder ein- und ausblenden und kann die Sache rotieren
Ach ja, und was ich ganz vergessen habe zu zeigen, es kann sogar GIFs abspielen und noch viel krasser GIFs rotieren
Und das ganze auf Knopfdruck, also sprich man hat quasi ein Overlay mit, das müssen ja keine Memes sein, das können irgendwelche Bilder sein, die man hinterlegt, du kannst dir quasi Shortcuts definieren, Steuerung M ist MonkaS, Steuerung L ist LUL
Und wenn du das gleich wieder drückst, blende das ein und aus, also quasi so das Memeport, also wenn man quasi streamt und irgendwie was sieht, was einblenden will und irgendwie grad mal sagt LUL, dann drückt man einfach den Shortcut und es ist da
Wo es komischerweise kein Windows Programm für gibt, ich hab keins gefunden
Und wisst ihr was das beste ist, das braucht glaube ich mal keine 10 MB Speicher, das Ding, hätten wir das ganze jetzt gemacht mit Elektron, dann hätten wir jetzt wahrscheinlich erst mal 250 MB RAM belegt und die Leute hätten sich 180 MB runterladen müssen dafür
Haus auf Git und wir machen das schön, mach ich, mach ich, wir laden das in GitHub hoch, mach ich morgen früh, bin hier nicht mehr eingeloggt, mach ich morgen früh, ich lad das auf GitHub hoch, weil wie gesagt es hat halt null Konfig-Möglichkeiten, aber Pull-Request nehme ich immer an
Malschrequest, nein Pull-Request, wir sind hier auf GitHub
Wie würde man das jetzt machen, wenn man will, dass die Memes in die Exe gepackt werden, also wie es mit WPF geht, bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher, wahrscheinlich geht es immer noch so, du kannst unter Windows Forms in die Resources hauen und dann Resources Load das Ding aufrufen, das geht
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass WPF immer noch funktioniert, ansonsten müsste ich mal überlegen, ansonsten kann man das bestimmt irgendwie reinpacken
Der Milchmann, Haus auf GitHub, ich mache einen Java-Port, dann bist du ein bisschen sicher, dass du das antun willst
NamelessKing, kannst du einem Mechatronik schon helfen, wie Klassen in C++ funktionieren, mit Konstruktor, Vererbung und so weiter, interessiert dich die Theorie dahinter, also sprich, wozu braucht man einen Konstruktor, objektorientierte Sache, Theorie, Methoden, Klassen, Vererbung und solche Sachen
Da interessiert dich wirklich einfach nur, wie es in C++ geht, weil wie es in C++ geht, das ist wahrscheinlich besser, wenn du dir ein Tutorial anguckst
Da ist ja nämlich auch erklärt, was an welcher Stelle passiert ist, aber von der Theorie kann ich da ein bisschen was zu erzählen, das ist ja in den meisten objektorientierten Sprachen ziemlich ähnlich
Fetzen-Randy, das ist aber nur die uralte Version von meinem Screenshot-Tool drin, in GitHub
Ich glaube, da ist sogar noch der komische Typ, der Typecast drin, den wir da aus Spaß rein gemacht haben, warte mal, muss ich mal gucken
Ach ne, ist das die DirectX Version sogar schon?
Ne, das ist nicht die DirectX Version, oder?
Ne, das ist nicht die DirectX Version
Wir haben schon längst weiter gemacht, eine Weile
Wo habe ich denn hier diesen eklichen Cast drin?
Irgendwo
Ach, keine Ahnung
Das ist schon längst, kannst du vergessen
An dem Tool machen wir dem Status gar nicht mehr weiter, wir sind ja schon viel weiter damit, das habe ich bloß nicht hochgeladen danach
Warum ist eigentlich, klappt es nicht, den Vordergrund mehr zu bringen?
So, ich muss mal gucken, ob der NamelessKing was geschrieben hat
Theorie wäre nicht schlecht, habe das mit dem Konstruktor nicht so verstanden, es gibt ja einen Standard-Konstruktor und einen, den man schreiben muss, wo liegt da der Unterschied?
Naja, der, also jetzt mal von den C++ spezifischen Sonderfällen, die es bestimmt gibt, und C++ kannst du eh alles machen, wie du willst
Abgesehen, ein Standard-Konstruktor ist implizit, der macht halt nichts
Der ruft die Basis-Klasse auf und falls in der Basis-Klasse was drin ist, dann wird das ausgeführt, aber ansonsten macht er nichts
Also wenn ich jetzt, machen wir mal ein neues Konsolen-Projekt, kann ich mal ein bisschen Objektorientierung was zu erzählen?
Eine Konsolen, nein ich will keine Konsolen-App.net Core
Also wenn ich jetzt hier einfach eine neue Klasse anlege, Klasse, Stream, irgendwas, dann geht das, die funktioniert und ich kann die auch anlegen
Und damit ich die Klasse quasi instanzieren kann, wie das in der Objektorientierung heißt, also quasi Stream gleich, Ups, Stream gleich, Alter mit der neuen Tastatur, ey
Ah habe ich, ich habe noch die indische Tastatur drauf
Damit ich sowas hier machen kann, new Stream, brauche die Klasse einen Konstruktor, standardmäßig hat die einen, der ist allerdings nicht notwendig, ihn explizit auszuschreiben, nämlich den Leeren
Der Leere macht nichts, zumindest nichts zusätzlich, außer das Notwendigste, was es irgendwie geht, was du brauchst, dass du ihm die Klasse anlegen kannst, bzw. die Instanz anlegen kannst
Wenn du jetzt eine Klasse hast, die von Stream erbt, dann musst du natürlich, bzw. dann wird standardmäßig der Konstruktor aufgerufen von der Klasse, von der du geerbt hast
Und wenn der irgendeinen Parameter braucht, dann musst du den auch bei der Klasse, von der du geerbt hast, angeben, weil den musst du ja beim Base-Konstruktor übergeben
Aber du brauchst keinen, aber du kannst natürlich einen definieren, wenn du was zusätzliches machen willst, entweder nimmst du halt eine Leere und kannst hier drin dann Zeugs anlegen
Was weiß ich, vielleicht musst du dir irgendwelche Bilder laden, oder musst du dir irgendwas aufräumen, oder irgendwelche anderen Sachen, was auch immer, was du halt machen musst
Dazu kannst du natürlich auch einen Konstruktor machen, der irgendwelche Parameter erfordert, und sobald du eine Klasse hast, die Parameter erfordert, musst du natürlich einen Konstruktor anlegen
Und den Parameterlosen wegmachen, dass man quasi gezwungen ist, den zu verwenden
Es kann ja sein, dass deine Klasse zwingend einen Namen braucht, ohne den sie nicht funktionieren kann
Es gibt allerdings noch ein paar Alternativen zum Konstruktor, es gibt ja verschiedene Ansätze, wie man Klassen instanziert
Java-Leute stehen zum Beispiel unglaublich auf Factories
Letztendlich wird dann auch ein Konstruktor von aufgerufen, ja klar, aber ist die Frage, wie man das macht
Achso, ja und dann, da bin ich mir nicht sicher, wie das bei C++ ist
Also, in C-Sharp geht das nicht
Du kannst in C-Sharp glaube ich nicht denjenigen, der deine Klasse verwendet, bzw. von deiner Klasse erbt, den kannst du glaube ich nicht zwingen, den Konstruktor zu überschreiben
Das ergibt doch eigentlich keinen Sinn, weil der zu deiner Klasse gehört, da musst du halt einen eigenen machen
Ob das in C++ geht, kein Schimmer, wird mich nicht wundern, C++ geht alles, würde ich aber nicht machen
Also man kann eine virtuelle Klasse machen und sagen, welche Methode derjenige, der davon erbt, überschreiben muss
Und eine abstrakte Klasse, welche er überschreiben muss
Zeig mal deine C++ Skills, ich hab den Qt-Creator nicht drauf, hab ich noch vom anderen Account
Ist C++ schwerer als Javascript?
Das kann man schlecht beantworten, C++ ist auf jeden Fall gefährlicher als Javascript
Also das ist eine Frage, wenn man darüber nachdenkt, die ist gar nicht so einfach zu beantworten
Weil C++ ist, wenn man sich wirklich darin auskennen will, wo ich gar nicht behaupte, dass ich das mache
Klar, ich kann in C++ auch ein paar GUIs basteln, das geht, aber wirklich auskennen ist in C++ gar nicht möglich
Das besteht aus so vielen Fallkrumen und so viel random Zeug, wo du eigentlich denkst, das kann doch so nicht sein
Dass es verdammt kompliziert ist, aber Javascript hat genauso viel Bullshit drinne
Und was bei Javascript eben noch dazu kommt, ist das sich ständig ändernde Javascript Ökosystem
Also sprich, wenn du dir heute mal angeguckt hast bei Javascript, welchen Paketmanager verwendest du
Welchen Transpiler, Transpiler ist auch so ein geiles Javascript, das gibt es nur da irgendwie
Zumindest nur da wird es so übertrieben
Welche irgendwie Transpiler, Targets und was auch immer du da nimmst für Javascript
Wenn du dir das heute angeguckt hast, kannst du davon ausgehen, in 5 Wochen ist es schon wieder komplett neu alles
Ich würde sagen, Javascript und C++ sind beide unglaublich kompliziert, wirklich gut zu sein drin
Aber auf komplett andere Art und Weise
Ist Stringbycsharp ein Typ?
Je nachdem, wie man es sieht, das ist ein Typ und das ist auch gleichzeitig ein Objekt
Ja klar, das ist ein Typ
Ja, bei 2KL Team
Ich finde Operator Overloading in begrenztem Maße okay, wenn man es teilweise so übertreibt
Ich finde es zum Beispiel in C++ so beknackt, dass irgendjemand auf die Idee gekommen ist
Teilweise für manche Sachen als Input sowas zu verwenden
Warum, warum, wozu, wo ist das Problem zu schreiben, Print, bla bla bla bla
Ja und wenn mir das nicht reicht, plus bla bla bla bla
Das ist ein Funktionsaufruf, jeder Depp erkennt, dass das ein Funktionsaufruf ist
Aber nein, in C++ steht man ja auch sowas, ja
Komplett im Kontrast zu allem anderen
Weil sich der Typ, der das programmiert hat, gedacht hat
Für Output wäre es mal ganz nett, man verwendet einfach zwei Pfeile
Ich weiß gar nicht, man kann wahrscheinlich in C++ auch sowas machen, aber das habe ich noch nie gesehen ehrlich gesagt
Ich weiß nicht, wer auf diese Idee gekommen ist
NamelessKing sagt, achso ich musste im Info Praktikum zwei Constructors erstellen
Dem Standard und einen der Parameter bekommen, die beide das gleiche machen
Wo ist der Sinn von einem parametrisierten Constructor, wenn er genau das gleiche macht wie der ohne Parameter
Wozu braucht man den Parameter denn dann
Was das Memetool am Ende können soll, zeige ich dir, wir sind schon fertig
Ich habe das von Unity Media Worder von Übernahme gehört, ja habe ich, klar, meisten werden wahrscheinlich schon was davon gehört haben
Das Memetool, was das kann
Das kann ihr Memes anzeigen
Wenn du das startest, dann kannst du hier unten Shortcuts definieren
Zum Beispiel Steuerung L und Steuerung L zeigt dir dann Aufwahl in allen anderen Programmen transparent LUL an
Kann im Prinzip alles anzeigen, was du einstellst
Drückst du M, zeigt er dir MonkaS an
Drückst du W, zeigt er dir hier Confused an
Drückst du nochmal W, brennt das wieder aus
Das ist halt ganz cool als Overlay, wenn du irgendwie was streamst und sagst hier LUL ist das lustig
Kannst du einen ausbrennen
Da kannst du noch sinnlos rotieren
Du kannst noch GIFs anzeigen lassen und GIFs noch mal zusätzlich sinnlos rotieren
Das war's, mehr kannst du nicht
So, was habe ich hier, ganz schön viel im Chat jetzt los auf einmal
Ich glaube wir wissen ob String ein primitiver Typ oder ein Objective Typ, das ist ein Objective Typ
Das ist ein Alias
String ist ein Alias
Also das String was man normalerweise verwendet für irgendwie hier so
Ist ein Alias auf String
Und Microsoft sagt dazu
Für Variablen Zuweisungen sollte man das hier für den Alias ein Typ nehmen
Für Parameteraufrufe der String Klasse, äh nicht für Parameter, für Funktionsaufrufe, Methodenaufrufe der String Klasse
Sollte man das hier verwenden
Sagt Microsoft und behauptet das ist lesbarer
Ich finde da haben sie recht, das ist lesbarer
Aber so würde das genauso funktionieren
Und so würde das auch funktionieren
Das ist ein Alias
String ist ein Alias auf String
Und das ist ein Objekt
Oder eine Klasse
Es ist gleiche
Also nicht, es ist nicht so wie in Java
Dass du da primitive Sachen hast und nicht
Also so Magic primitive Sachen und nicht
Das ist besser gemacht
Und meine Klimaanlage kurz ausschalten
Bisschen kühl
Das macht man nur bei Streams
Genau
Dafür ist es da, für Streams
Dafür ist es da, für Streams, das Memboard
Der BlackDead sagt ein Kumpel von mir kann C++ Code schreiben
Der ist so wirr, dass man den nicht versteht
Wenn man nicht weiß, was der Programm macht
Du kannst in jeder Programmiersprache Code schreiben, den keiner sauber versteht
Das ist überhaupt kein Problem
In C++ gehts besonders einfach
In Java geht das auch besonders einfach
In Javascript geht das noch viel einfacher
Du kannst sogar in Python kannst du
Und in Ruby besonders kannst du Program Code schreiben, den keiner sauber versteht
In Perl hast recht
Du kannst aber auch C sauber schreiben
Das geht
Man muss sich halt ein bisschen am Riemen reißen
Und nicht unbedingt
Was C Programmierer ja gerne machen
Ist ja
C Programmierer machen ja sowas hier gerne
Sowas machen, das machen C Programmierer
Das machen die ultra gerne
Dass der am Ende nicht weiß, was was ist
So als müsstest du im Source Code
Müsstest du Bytes sparen
Da stehen die irgendwie drauf
Z